Oh you dirty freaks.
It is
Monday April 22nd.
Two days after 420 and I'm here with my man Tony Hinchcliffe.
He has never been an individual guest on the podcast for but we've done podcast
before under the Icehouse Chronicles which by the way is available on the desk
one label on iTunes as well as the whole areas.
KEVIN PEREIRA As podcast called pointless muff said if you want to hear chicks
talk about sucking decks and stuff.
Oh that's video games and comic books.
Well how about we just give him a little false advertising.
Brian maybe.
Maybe you get more people don't you know what this country runs on son.
No I'm upset with what's right.
Ryan killed Ryan Kelly.
Very very funny and talented Ryan Keeling and Brian also does a gang of shows
and he's doing some soon in San Francisco and Sacramento at the punch line in
Sacramento.
And with this man Tony Hinchcliffe you'll be there as well.
And what were we doing the apples here.
Yeah I was talking about this.
Tony.
Tony it's because finance.
I was Tony road.
It's great.
He cries when you fuck him.
But.
Here here here here.
But tell that to legendary comedy clubs Sam Tripoli as well our boy Sam Tripoli
who's one of my very good friends in comedy for many many years.
He's a fucking beautiful human being I love that guy and very funny as well.
And so they are at Cobb's on Sunday May 5th and May 3rd and 4th they're at the
punch line in Sacramento.
And if you've never been to the punch line in Sacramento I've never been to a
comedy club.
The punch line in Sacramento is like one of the perfect comedy clubs to go to
because it's been around for ever.
This as well as places like I don't remember the first time I worked there.
But it was well over a decade ago it's a bad ass old school comedy club and some
great great great comedy has been done on that stage perfectly set out really
intimate seating.
So it's a bad ass place to see three very funny guy.
So May 3rd and 4th at the punch line in Sacramento and May 5th at Cobb's and in
San Francisco and there might be a surprise guest there might not be though too
there might not be may be AIDS get stronger maybe World War Z is for real but
maybe there's gonna be a big guest maybe there's a lot a lot of times you can't
say because the reason being I'd say if you're doing a show like this like we
might have a friend that's in town it says hey I want to do the show but they
don't want to advertise because they have a committed gig within X amount of
miles with an X amount of months and sometimes not supposed to say that you're
doing a gig like that's why.
Like if you go to like some some guys you don't have a hard time with the Comedy
Store for putting your name up there because they would have like a gig they
were doing in a big place or try to sell tickets for.
So we'd have an arrangement.
So that's why I can't say but it might be someone very funny.
It might be somebody that hardly ever leaves L.A.
and hardly ever leaves the Comedy Store.
Mm hmm.
Wow this is exciting.
I want to know who it is.
Okay.
I don't even know who the fuck it is yet.
I think I do.
If if it is I think it is he's awesome.
Yeah they're the comedy stores that means 80 percent awesome.
You know even the 20 percent mediocre it's probably better than what you got in
your town anyway.
Yeah.
So you're a powerful Ryan Keeley mob said All right you guys.
We.
This podcast is brought to you by Tang.
I'm so glad that when when we we pick up a podcast sponsor you're always like oh
what if these kinds of douche bags you know like what if that's like a big fear
you know when you take on a sponsor because you know I'm on network I don't have
a channel I'm just you know I'm just doing this thing and I'm trying to like
navigate all this stuff by myself.
So
my attitude with the whole thing was I looked and I said the most important
thing first of all is that I don't feel duty like whatever we're selling and
everybody's like then it's too late for you know for brain do she.
You know I just want to make sure that what we're selling is a good product.
So I get all these emails and tweets tweets especially sometimes about talking
about people saying how much money they're saving on Tang and guy one guy talked
about it a couple of weeks ago.
He wrote to me.
He chopped his bill down from 90 bucks to like 18.
I don't know how the fuck he did I know what he's doing.
That sound sounded completely outrageous.
Well my bill has been that guy about twenty five dollars a month.
I mean and I have to say that this is my second phone and this is you know my
massage parlor phone.
Dan would you say that you use it 50 percent as much as you earlier your other
phone or I'd probably say my other phone I use it 50 percent more maybe it's
maybe a little bit a little bit higher maybe 60 maybe six.
So probably be the equivalent of sixty dollars someone like that would you say
that.
Yeah that makes sense.
Yeah.
So if that's still him it's still cheaper than then what like.
Right now I have you know the iPhone through AT&T as my main phone and that's
about one hundred and twenty two hundred ten dollars a month.
You
know it's fucking very pricey.
Yeah.
What thing does is they first of all they use the Sprint network then have their
own network these one of the major networks in this country one that you know
it's it's got 4G it's it's excellent and they also have the highest level of the
most technologically advanced Android phones all these new fucking killer
Android phones like the Samsung Galaxy S3 and the Samsung Galaxy Note They have
the note 2 as well they're fucking incredibly things he used to be like you
really lost something if you didn't get an iPhone like you really have you try
to have one of those early Android they were dog shit.
I had the first one was Oh you're so stupid those things are horrible that and
those BlackBerry touch screens these to have eyes to have one of those the
BlackBerry Storm.
Yeah fuckin storm of shit.
So that was diarrhea and that's stupid shit bag phone but these SAMs I have the
Galaxy S3 it's fucking awesome it's great it's the coolest thing ever for like
looking at websites.
It's huge and it's very fast as well like the processor and it's not like clunky
like like the droids of all.
So anyway the waiting has it set up is they have no contracts so you buy a
device set it up and go.
You can go fuck yourself you could just cancel not only that they credit you on
unused service if you if you use only a certain amount of your bill they
actually like knock you down to the next level and your next bill and they
credit you the difference it's it's beautiful it's everything you could ask for
from a big company like a company that's dead I mean they're not one of the
bigger cell phone companies.
I mean how many cell phone companies are there actually really stop thinking
well there's like the big five or whenever you like T-Mobile Ryan Verizon AT&T
it's like you generally thought of it's like this it's like a rise in powerful
AT&T powerful T-Mobile you're on a budget yeah yeah.
Right now it is it's crazy because T-Mobile as you know they're new towers are
pretty advanced and they don't have that fucking you know bandwidth hogs that
you know AT&T and Verizon they're their bandwidth I mean so many people are on
their network when something goes down half the people have Verizon or AT&T you
know they're not gonna have cell phone service but then you have like T-Mobile
guys they're like No I'm fine.
That's a very good point.
Yeah.
And Sprint is a big one.
Joey Diaz That's him forever.
He loved it.
I've never had it other than this but I've got no problems with it.
Yeah and the though the whole idea behind thing is that they're just going to
offer you a service that's you know it's just it's reasonable.
You don't have to get fucked over it doesn't have to be this idea that we all
think that every company should try to squeeze every last dollar out of every
last customer.
I think that shit's stupid.
I think most people rise up realizing that as well.
So go to Rogan distinction and you can save yourself twenty five dollars off of
either a phone or service from a very cool company were also brought to you by
square space.
So you have to ask yourself do you want to make a web site.
Bitch that's my question to you bitch.
Do you want make a web site.
And if you do let's get a real young guy learn no HMO OK.
You're not going to use it.
It's just not gonna happen.
Okay let's be honest.
Another thing
you don't need to begin to you to really learn how to put all that shit in and
it's gonna be all fucked up and then you gonna try to what look at it unlike
Windows Internet Explorer.
It's going to shit.
But look it works on safari.
You don't have to do that anymore.
What square space you can go there and you can create your own Web site.
It's so easy that you can setup a store just like that Bryant did it while we
were doing the commercial Bryant registered a fucking thing on square space
started.
What was it called.
And it was all on the servers.
Now that was a different looks.
However you did for square space 2.
No I made a web site but if you're thinking of I bought Digg party.
Oh you'd buy Digg party my mouth dot com dot com although and then didn't you.
But didn't you build a website with square space.
Yeah.
I did a dolphin.
Sex dolphin website.
I tried to do it right now.
It's Brian.
Look Brian is much more technically advanced than or aware than I'll ever be.
He can throw one of these fucking things together very quickly and he did it
through square space.
You know why we're just all still doing a show as well.
It's super easy if you go to square space dot com forward slash job.
You can sign up with no credit card needed and just try it out.
You just start building a website and if you decide to purchase use the offer
code Joe 4 and Joe and 4 for April.
That's all one word or one thing.
Joe for.
And then you get 10 percent off your first purchase on new accounts includes
monthly and annual plans.
And again that square space dot com forward slash Joe.
And if you're going to enter in the code use the code Joe for CSL some shekels
sun on your fat juicy Web site.
It's
definitely I can create a Web site on this.
In a way that I never could in real life because I am just way too HDD for that
shit.
I'm not going to learn and do that.
I had to.
I have one where I'm trying to keep up with but this looks this looks even
better.
It's dope pretty easy.
Super easy.
Yeah yeah it's good.
Go get it.
So delicious.
We're also brought to you by Audible dot com.
I was actually listening to.
Do you know why I got hooked on man.
I'm hooked on now.
How dare you.
I read super awesome Dan Carlin's Hardcore History.
Oh yeah.
Dude.
God damn.
Ever since we had a guy on the show we had on a podcast.
Guy was great to talk to.
Fascinating guy.
Really really interesting intelligent guy but when it comes to history he's been
putting together like forever.
He's been putting together these history podcasts and they're like a show.
It's not like a podcast like this sloppy unorganized mass that I try to fucking
serve up to Fox.
Dan Carlin puts on a god damn show and he he puts it on in like this really
entertaining way and gives you this thorough history of all these events but
like really exciting stuff.
What are you doing.
You chatting with Kara.
I care.
I'm single you.
Hey dude how dare you.
How dare you even give people the idea to do that.
No care is gonna be super upset with you and probably sue this show.
Fine.
I'll see what I'm here is like some super hardcore feminist and she's like
enough Joe Rogan.
What if she's in India fingering yourself.
Oh easy over here with the thing is I'm on hardcore history.
I'm on the.
The Mongols.
Now he's got this.
I don't know how many parts it is.
I mean part 3.
It's fucking amazing.
It's so great and it's available on audible dot com.
He's got all the back episodes.
I mean he's been doing it since I think he said 2005.
So you know this guy's got a solid eight years of podcasts under him.
It's crazy and they're awesome.
I listened to one on Germany in World War 2 the bombings of Europe.
He's so fucking cool to listen to.
It's really bad ass if you go to all we've got Audible dot com Ford slash Joe.
You can try audible free for 30 days and get a free audio book not just that
they also have standup comedy on there they have a huge selection of audio
entertainment not just books but podcasts like Hardcore History and and so many
other really interesting things to listen to including our pals Opie and
Anthony.
You can you can get that on audible as well.
It's a cool service and I've been a fan for years.
I'm a huge fan of audio books this Hardcore History has been making my life like
so much more interesting the last couple of days.
Like when I get in my car I'm not like thinking oh you know you get my car and
drove and probably stuck in traffic I'm going to go all let's hear more about
the Mongols.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's just Genghis Khan was a mother fucker.
Yeah dude King Kong killed almost 70 million people by some counts.
Some accounts say more than that.
Some accounts say but as little as 10 million.
Like He definitely killed 10 million.
God damn it's unbelievable.
That's the best.
They're talking about armies that were coming towards China where the Mongols
had been and in the distance they thought they saw snow covered mountains.
But when they got close they realized there were mounds of bones.
Oh my God.
The Mongols had killed 10 million people in this one town they came to this
gigantic state and just killed 10 million people.
It was amazing.
I mean horrific terrifying.
Just the idea that that at one point in time just in the twelve hundred's
relatively short amount of time ago there was a guy who brought a bunch of other
dudes with him on horseback and just fucked up the whole world banded together
took hostages took the hostages pushed them to the front lines so the hostages
would literally lead the way and people would be defending their towns having to
shoot arrows at their own friends who had been kidnapped their own loved ones
their own children the Mongols were fucking terrifying.
It's terrifying to think that just a thousand years ago not even there was a
dude who figured out a way to get hundreds of thousands of mass murderers to
work together.
Hundreds of thousands of serial killers.
Hundreds of thousands of brutal rapists.
Hundreds of thousands of ruthless remorseless murderers.
And they got together on horseback.
It takes one convincing leader.
God damn Genghis Khan must have been a mother fucker because there was nobody
like that before and nobody liked that since his sons tried to hang on to it for
a little while but you know what.
The reign of power all really came through that one bad motherfucker.
They had a crazy saying that an armies of donkey led by a lion could conquer an
army of lions led by a donkey.
They were all about tactics and they would beat much larger armies with severe
superior strategy and cunning and just ruthlessness.
Just everybody was terrified of them.
They just they killed everybody man men women children babies they didn't give a
fuck.
They killed everybody.
They eight people.
They hate each other.
They got too hungry.
They would draw straws maybe or figure out how they would figure out you know if
someone's gonna sacrifice themselves so that the army could go on and they would
slaughter them and eat them and cook them.
Dude it's unbelievable.
I was only a thousand years ago.
What the fuck man.
You think it will ever anybody else ever pull that off again.
That kind of craziness that's terrifying to wonder.
I think if you had to worry about anything it would be worry about all this
beautiful city shit shutting down.
That's the real fear.
The real fear is we have some massive disaster like a solar flare that knocks
out our power grid and our ability to pump gas is gone.
Our ability to drive back and forth to places is gone.
Our ability to get food people's gone and then you realize how nutty we are
spread out and how dangerous this is and how vulnerable we are living like this.
I think you would take something like that to bring people to some place where
you could get that many psychopaths all together again.
Yeah I think now that we have the internet if the Internet went down I think
shit we get crazy really quick because everybody needs it and is used to it now.
Everything down to the G.P.S.
and just everything.
Yeah we're terrified.
I'm terrified of leaving leaving the house that my fucking cell phone right.
I'm a little bitch.
I'm a little bitch the machine.
Speaking of machine we're talking about the human machine.
Our last sponsor on it dot com.
We sell all kinds of cool shit to get your Fitness on.
We've got kettle bells battle robes.
The newest edition weight vests.
No that's not armor Bryan.
It's a weight vest.
It's not armor even though it pride protect you a little bit.
There we go.
We also have steel Masons and steel clubs.
These are not weapons.
These are designed for functional athletic improvement.
What all these things that were selling like kettle bells and battle ropes.
They're all for what's to develop what's best to develop what they call
functional strength.
We have medicine balls as well functional strength.
We sell a pull up bar functional strength like the ability to move your body
around as one unit.
It's one of the most important aspects of fitness and one of the things that
people screw up on is if they try to get in shape.
They don't know what the fuck they're doing they do like too many bicep curls or
too many like bench presses and shit you can whack your body out making it
imbalanced.
It's one of the best ways to get fit like a full body fit is to do things that
require you to use the body as one unit.
I'm obsessed with that.
Obviously that's why I talk about it every week but I've seen massive
improvements for my jujitsu athletic benefits of training like this and I always
encourage people to do it because really fun too.
And you can get a great workout and literally in 20 minutes you could do a
brutal Kettlebell workout in 20 minutes.
Follow a DVD that Keith Webber DVD that we have the extreme kettlebell DVD is
fucking awesome and follow 20 minutes of it you'll get crushed and you'll you'll
feel good you feel fantastic so go there good on it.
Comments.
I win in 90 lots of different supplements we have now vitamin C and l lysine and
we sell melatonin spirulina Arctic cod liver oil we're trying to sell you just
the best shit for your health and for fitness and things along those lines and
if you use the codename Brogan You will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
How long.
How long till you have like a health helmet.
If we if it comes out do we'll sell it.
If there's a health element that comes out that puts you in a healthy state of
mind.
What if there was a helmet that came on that immediately felt like someone was
sucking your dick.
How.
How quick before they would make that illegal.
Like immediately like they found a spot on your brain where they can joke with
electricity and it totally feels like someone's sucking your dick a helmet that
helps your helmet a helmet for your helmet.
Exactly how much do you think they would make that women would make that
illegal.
Would it be men and maybe a little bitch about it a lot of men would make it
illegal because they'd never get real blow jobs over again girls.
But just put the fucking helmet on kind of why do you want me to do this.
It'd be a tough situation for women if the helmet worked that well it came.
You think they would lose a little bit of their value.
Is that what you're saying.
Oh yeah I think I should be walking her out these helmets on helmet.
What's the normal thing.
How much time do you think it is before something like that is invented
something that can recreate an artificial experience like almost almost exactly.
I'll bet you 15 20 years.
I bet it's not that far away.
The way things are moving and shaking there's probably a bigger team of
scientists on that right now than there is on cancer research.
You're right.
Everybody is building the helmet.
Everybody wants to get their dicks sucked and then wrote on it.
Thought Tom Ford slashed Joe.
Cue the music Brian.
Let's get this bitch started.
Boom son
the will gain experience.
We're full Tony.
George Clooney.
That's me.
That's the song.
That's the powerful Tony Hinchcliffe song.
I say it like that.
I sing like a woman.
And then you go.
That's me like a little kid.
Hey everybody.
Somebody put that on a loop when you have your own podcast.
What are you guys going to do a podcast that once you guys where it are in the
works it starts Oh okay Lucky.
Two weeks.
I think we sat in preproduction.
Yeah niceness niceness until he's gonna be with me on this Wednesday night at
the icehouse went to the ice ones it.
Sure.
10:00.
OK.
Brian's going to be there too as well as Tom Seger and Burt Krisha.
Oh shit bitches.
That's right.
You heard sweet.
Tony is an up and coming young standup.
I love one of my favorite things in life for real.
This really is absolutely true is when I don't know about someone and then I
find out that they're funny.
Like when I found out about it from Brian.
Brian told me about you.
And as a comedian like one of things that every comedian always loves is seeing
a new comedian like some.
Someone who knew who's funny like does another one say oh there's another one
you know and different styles and different you know different takes but when
they're funny like it's really it gives you a lot of hope.
And I was I was in L.A.
the entire time like you started comedy and you know and then started getting a
little a name for yourself.
And then eventually got to the point where you're you know regularly doing you
know podcasts and comedy clubs and yeah.
So that's that's a really cool thing to say.
Yeah it's really so much fun.
Pretty incredible.
So few people pull it off.
You know I love watching somebody who comes through like some new person is
funny.
It's like because we to all the class thing and like you said everybody's a
little bit different.
Everybody has their you know their take on things.
But when you find one there's nothing cooler it's sort of like when you love
comedy it's like watching a baby being born like just like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Larson's hilarious and when.
You know like you when you run into someone and you you realize that you know
they started out sucky and you probably saw them in like those during those
first couple of months.
And then within a couple of years they become competent and then boom they
become really good and they like like Ari is my favorite example.
Oh yeah.
I was there when Ari first got on stage like one of his first sets one of the
earliest sets.
And you know I've watched him become like a real killer like Ari Shapiro is like
a real killer.
He did.
Tom Seger is party of day top scorer had a benefit rather for his doggy.
He got a sick dog.
If you if you love dogs you love Tom Segura.
I don't know how you would donate.
I think they have like a paper out there so don't go to your mom's house podcast
on your mom's house podcast dot com.
Tom Sawyer is just one of the coolest guys ever.
And he had the show and Ari went up and fucking destroyed destroyed with a bunch
of shit that I hadn't heard before to those couple bits that were really funny
that were new.
He writes like a machine.
Yeah he's awesome.
He's isn't here.
He's just coming up with so much content.
Yeah.
I think he also realizes at this time that he's like you know he's again he's
like a real comic now.
Now it's just a matter of doing the work.
And he's a smart dude you know he knows how to he knows how to put it down.
He knows what needs to be done and he can go get it done just as as a fan of
comics.
It's so cool and someone pops up.
There's another one I got really lucky with Ari because he was the first person
I asked me to do a gig with him and Sam Tripoli.
So was those two guys all of a sudden all at once I went to La Hoya with Sam
first and then did a gig and like Irvine with Ari.
What year was this.
This is about 2008.
That's so recently.
That's awesome.
Five years I don't think of it as being recently but you know there was like a
year or so that I was doing it before you even get a road gig like that you're
just building it.
I was you know just riding my bicycle from open mike to open mike.
How many guys that started out with you.
You know we all have like kind of like groups of people that we sort of start
off around a similar time and then you watch each other either fall off or give
up or are some people get through the net.
How many people that with your class do you think got through with my true
class.
I'd probably say about good.
It's a tough one because we're still pulling you know and I mean you still don't
know who can make like a bit throw a right hook right at the end before they
drop out and have a new 15 minutes the crushes and it's a breakthrough.
But I probably guess about seven or ten right around there.
That's a good number.
Like still doing I mean you know I'm counting my original starting classes like
a good you know 60 70 80 90 right people because I know the I mean I stayed in
Hollywood and built in Hollywood like Los Angeles because I feel like a lot of
people start somewhere and then come to L.A.
I'm like You know what I'm going to.
I wanted to just have a like an NBA style perspective like Chappelle once said
and he was doing a spot on stage one night and the LR really late crushing
making it look like I mean it was just unbelievable.
And the three or four hours and he goes the back Laramie goes hey how many guys
are L.A.
comics and a lot of people clapping.
But how many of you are like work here at the Comedy Store and started here at
the Comedy Store.
That was just two or three of us that clap.
He goes You guys are insane.
He's performing to a lot of comedians right.
So the thing with him coming back a few years ago was like the audience that got
to be there was there but the back of the room filled up to the gills.
Right.
And he said that it's like learning how to dribble in the NBA starting comedy at
the Comedy Store.
And it's so true.
But but if you think about that start learning how to dribble in the NBA and
you're you and you're just used to the motion of a thousand miles an hour.
Yeah then that works out.
I think it's like anything else.
You know it's a more difficult but also more rewarding pursuit pursuit.
You know you can take an easy route through life or you can you know I mean it's
not as hard as being a Navy SEAL.
Let's be honest you know even though doing comedy is hard and a lot of people
don't ever figured out it's not nearly as hard as doing something you hate and
being stuck working 40 hours a week at this job for the rest of your life until
your heart stops beating because you have no passion right.
And I mean it was a real struggle for a few years I really threw myself to the
wolves.
I didn't have sure I didn't have money saved up.
I was just I was just doing it and then I got the job working at the Comedy
Store a couple of months and like as a door guy.
So I started getting spots a lot there which is what I wanted.
You know the problem the story like yours is that it worked.
So there's a lot of the dudes out there that will try that same thing but
they're not fucking funny at all.
You know what's tough is it is I noticed that a lot a lot of people come up to
me and say I'm thinking about starting standup Tony.
You know what do you what do you think and sometimes they don't they just
sometimes I wonder out of all the times I get asked this from somebody that
wants to start standup it's like you have to really have a crazy mind ingrained
in you it's not something you start and learn like.
I was in trouble.
Every class in school not once a day at school like every class every teacher
hated me.
I never touched and I was never like spilled milk on somebody I never did
anything physical but verbally I was just.
It's the it's what I did is pretty crazy.
And I mean you know like so you just always talk to Russia totally to the
extreme all the time.
And that's that's like Kid energy you know I'm talking about the fun even now.
Now I'm like I'll even.
I'm still young it's like I'm not half of the quick wit that I used to be before
I realized I wasn't now I overthinking is a defense thing you learned it from
your parents like I learned of you Dad.
It's really an interesting situation is the way I raised I was raised with so
weird that I know it has something to do with that because I have these four
older brothers and sisters that are much older than me.
So it's like I mean it's 12 years between me and my closest sibling and they're
all much older.
Oh wow yeah.
So you probably exposed to like they probably give you a hard time and pretty
fucked with you really they were absolutely all super cool.
They were actually super cool.
That's how I and that's sometimes I wonder how it didn't end up like that.
I mean there were times you know there was the old you know you were adopted.
Why do you think you're.
Well you know what.
When they're 12 years apart I don't think you're actually going to get them
because they're gonna be sweet to you you're like happy for a little brother and
sister.
It's when you two years apart you know.
Yeah I've I've known a lot of brothers beat the fuck out of each other.
Yeah.
Obviously that album Luckily with the age gap like they were in college when I
was you know in kindergarten and stuff.
What was interesting about that is I definitely think it played a role because I
was hanging out with 20 year olds when I was a little kid and they probably
thought I was really funny when you talk shit too.
Totally.
This whole thing.
That's what I would do I would talk shit and I would put on terrible magic shows
in which the whole ongoing joke was that you can clearly see you know I had not
seen comedian magicians right yet.
I was just trying to do magic but I was bad at it but I could just the way I
like that and well it started I had to get good at doing it on purpose because
it was happening accidentally and I would just try to follow through with it.
So you started off trying to be good.
Yeah
right.
But then I just got good at being that magic.
Yeah it's a funny thing when you see someone who grew up like in a weird spot
like that.
I think all of us like every comic I know grew up in some sort of a weird
situation where some basic need wasn't fulfilled.
So that creates like this weird personality.
Totally.
I even though I love comics when that when it doesn't create that weird
personality it just creates fucked up people you know like if you don't put it
to use like creating something that weird energy that comes out of a weird life.
If you did that shit will haunt you like that can that can wreck your life if
you're one of those really creative people or more impulsive people and doesn't
do anything about it don't doesn't focus in on something yeah.
And it's just that's an interesting point because with me I didn't have any
creative outlet until like after high school because the theater woman always
wanted me to join theater.
Yeah but I never did.
And I mean the only outlet other than doing it in front of people all the time
and just you know being me I had nothing.
So then I spent a few years like what am I.
Because you don't know
if you're just a kid that loves making people laugh that you can be a standup
comedian right.
When you're in Ohio there's no people in L.A.
are really lucky or in New York around those areas because there's comedy there
at least you can stumble across a comedy club and go and wonder what's going on
there.
I might go in there tonight just one time.
First time I was ever at a comedy club was at the Comedy Store and I had signed
up for the open mike and gotten on.
So it's very grandiose.
I mean you know it's like my heart was beating out of my chest.
I knew that it was something I was gonna be doing forever no matter what how you
knew it.
You know it was something I definitely didn't know the first time I went on
stage
I was I was scared shitless to the waist.
More scared than I thought I was going to be.
Oh I never I It is unbelievable.
It is so creepy because what ended up happening was is I've blanked out and
forgot everything that I'd been and that was the one time that I was I had a
couple months to prepare for three minutes.
Did you bring notes on stage with you.
No I never liked.
I've never liked having notes onstage with me.
That was a big thing man getting rid of your notes.
I was a big thing back in the day.
Going on stage with notes still.
Yeah.
Because in the beginning I definitely went on stage with notes when I first
started doing it but I saw like really good guys go on stage with notes when
they were working on new shit.
Yeah it became like part of the act that they let you know they were trying
stuff out by looking down at the paper.
But you try to do the first one free ball.
Yeah like really bad in a I somehow was just digging myself out by calling out
how terrible it was.
I just I was basically saying Wow I just blanked out.
And I've been getting ready for this for so long and so I just ended up doing
what actually ended up sort of becoming my style which is like calling out
whatever's happening in the room except I was just joking about me bombing.
You kind of have to call out what's happened in the room right.
Oh yeah.
And that's that's one.
Another good thing rather that the comedy store provides no crowd control.
Right.
None.
That place is madness.
There's something I could be madness.
That's why I like it was so modern.
Anything can happen at the Comedy Store.
So like for example like when we did that show in Indianapolis and I came out
and I'm looking at the masses of people but the first thing that I notice to my
left is this lady lit up next to the stage that's doing sign language to the to
the audience.
And I just couldn't help but the start like I always say you know it started
just with I've never performed in front of one of these people before.
I've always wondered what that would be like.
And I'm noticing that she has to keep up with everything that I'm saying.
So like I went off on this whole run about it that it's just so much fun for me
and I could trust my instinct and just keep going with it because I even though
like I wouldn't have known to do that if I was just trying to just put on like
an act.
Right.
Yeah.
Which is also great.
But I got to go off on a run there and I could trust that instinct you know by
the end I have her doing blow job motions to her face because I realized that if
I said the word blow job she has to do that jerk off that is on her face or off
on the face is the that's the sign language for that.
Yeah.
This is blow job or at least that's what she was doing.
Actually was he because they switched halfway through the whole thing but they
switched the trick was like enough tone handling so I think so I just quit.
I don't I don't know what happened how did you have a backup so close that you
they get tired I guess so signing maybe you need like really good hand cardio
but not being crazy.
I had you know crazy a ton of tweets.
Indianapolis was so much fun and everybody was like hash tagging sign language
because I couldn't even believe what was going on.
Yeah I did that once in San Francisco a guy brought his own remember that.
Yeah.
And he sat right in the front.
Guy brought his own sign person.
I was like wow that's pretty gangster.
Guy was deaf.
You want to go see some comedies like I'm tell you they're saying Yeah you look
really nice guys.
That was a fun show.
He did.
I forget what he did because it was a I was obviously timing things he didn't
talk.
It was really funny.
It was really funny like you could tell the guy like really enjoyed standup
comedy.
And even though he was deaf he still understood.
Like what.
You know he understood jokes.
It's got to be weird because he's only getting it like two dimensional.
Right.
You don't if you don't hear it.
Yeah man you're missing so much.
Like there's a lot of guys like Joey Díaz perfect example of you half of what's
funny is how he sounds like you know the way sounds is the fucking intensity of
his voice.
Well it's like when he when he hits those six when he starts screaming about
something like he was screaming about it's blue cheese with buffalo wings or go
fuck your mother it was just fucking ranch dressing.
He went on his rant about ranch dressing and on paper it's like there's nothing
funny about that at all.
But if you hear him if you hear Joe and you see him do it.
It was one of the finest fucking things I've seen with other passion the arms
from deep but I mean maybe this guy had like a deep sense of his own timing.
You know he can interpret it in the finest way because he was obviously a fan of
stand up comedy enough to hire his own sign language person.
Yeah I've been at a college show once were they they made them have a sign
language it was like a part of the rules.
Like if someone spoke they had to have someone there.
That's a I was wondered how complicated is that sign language.
I mean it seems like it seemed really I was watching some parts of it because at
one point when you were on I walked around and sort of was watching from the
side ledge area and I noticed that when you said the word at one point polite
cock this guy had to do this thing where it was this giant like right.
Well that's the strap on bit.
Right.
Well it was it was something.
It was when you were taking questions at the end it was like you were talking
about Dennis Rodman's cock or something like that.
He was like oh very improvised.
Oh the Kim Jong Il thing I was noticing this guy has to do this thing like that
black cock and sign language.
Is this.
It's like so stereotypical like it's just giant and his hands were so far apart
it is like he was describing a tree stump or something like that.
Like this hand climbing.
I'm like that's black cock and sign language.
Isn't that hilarious.
That's what they would come up with.
That's the move.
Yeah.
So blow job is this.
I don't know why it's down.
Why does it go down.
It seems that you're always on your knees.
But that's an awkward angle tells us to do your blog.
That is why it would be I see a blond giant.
Like a child made sign me.
You know if so get on a chair.
That's ridiculous angle to have that standard angle to suck a dick and doesn't
make any sense at all.
I'm not going to fire it.
You almost killed.
So the first time may say laugh just thinks it was brilliant at the time was
absolutely brilliant.
It was the perfect time if at first you don't succeed.
Phi Phi again.
To you guys get a room get a room.
Yeah.
Fuck
yeah.
We're gonna have to share a room when we're in the same Sacramento.
I'm sharing a room.
And so why you sharing rooms.
Because listen getting your own rooms you fucking weirdo.
Grown men stop pretending like you're in high school.
OK we're going to get up to her door we're gonna go fishing.
Get a hotel room together.
Shut the fuck up to get your own room.
God damn it was thirty dollars and ninety cheap fuck thirty dollars a night.
Well have you seen the commercials.
We'll keep the light on for you.
Thirty dollars and thirty bucks.
Joe we were talking about it on a recent podcast.
I think you're there Tony.
I think it was Ari was saying it was he was talking about how funny it was going
to the grocery store with you because like you'd be like you know how much is
macaroni or pasta sauce like you know 20 dollars whatever it was.
What is toothpaste.
Two dollars.
I don't know what I think.
I haven't forever.
Eddie Bravo always makes fun of it says that I would be the worst person ever on
the price is right now because I literally don't know anything costs.
So far there's only room enough my fucking hand for so much show against it.
There's no room for that.
I just got no room for as long as people aren't riding the streets over the
price of toothpaste.
If they are then I'll start paying attention.
It's like I've got shit to do.
I can't be worrying about what shit costs as long as it's fairly reasonable.
But I have friends that are like wealthy and you hear them go a steak for thirty
nine dollars.
Are you telling me that the state cost thirty nine dollars.
Why is this steak three.
Hey just what are you What are you doing.
What do you do it's a number.
So what does it even mean.
What the fuck is it even based on.
Just shut your mouth.
You're not broke.
Spend the thirty nine bucks you cheap fuck you whining asshole you yammering
fucking perspective lapping douche bag.
You know we'll get it together you fuck.
I went something a real person.
Oh what's that Morton's Steakhouse is a wonderful place.
Yeah I love it and I was just in that it was the only place near me that had
crab legs and it cause I was just since Vegas I've been thinking about those
crab legs from Vegas and I'm 9 yeah from 9 which is most amazing place ever so I
went there to get on and a half pound was sixty like sixty five dollars and I
was like That's a lot.
You get a lot.
Four legs is what it was.
But did you watch that show with the dudes die.
Get on those fucking crab boats.
No I didn't.
That's that's why it's so much it's because it's really hard to get.
That's what world Deadliest Catch with.
This is what I was getting at.
Then the two days later I was thinking like that didn't I want wanted more.
Know I wanted to eat right.
Right.
You know what I mean.
So then I went to Olive Garden and they had a weight.
So I went to the place next door and stay which is like Outback Steakhouse and
they had them there and they they had a pound for 40 dollars and then you can
add another half pound for 15 bucks.
So I cut a pound and a half for the fries and it tasted pretty much exactly the
same.
You could tell that it came out like when you pulled it out it was like a little
sweet little harder.
I guess.
Nice buttery mushy as the plate but still tastes exactly the same.
So you think they just overcooked it.
Maybe.
I think they're frozen obviously you know that you could try to tell they did
well I think they're all frozen quite honestly because they're coming from
Alaska.
Well I was thinking that's why when the morning sucks I was like Oh that place
probably gets it.
Yeah.
Well they just know how to fucking do everything right.
There's certain places like you know Morton's there's that other one Flemings
you ever heard of Flemings.
Yeah.
There's a whole chain of those things they just know what the fuck they're
doing.
You know they sexually work at Ruth's Chris Steakhouse.
Wait a minute hold on a second.
I.
I know what you said but I thought I sexually worked at Ruth's Chris Steakhouse.
That's why I heard you say
that stuff.
I was like.
I mean what the fuck did he say.
And that places and then I realized there was a slurring or a I used actually I
sexually.
So I say I used to actually sing as well you know if you ever heard someone
speak in another language and there was a little there's they're just rattling
off and you if you don't know what they're saying you could never discern that
there's more than one word going on that you don't know when one stops at
another one ends.
That was a classic example that I used to actually you know that's what does
that.
That's not a word.
It's like a Jeff Dunham bit or something.
No not Jeff Dunham.
What's his name.
I might be a redneck guy Fox or Foxworthy.
Jeff Foxworthy doesn't have a dad like dark here like like things he would write
down like D G E 80s DG.
It's.
Like you know there is like red and a redneck vocabulary.
Have you ever seen that show Swamp People.
Well they just alligator hunting.
Holy fuck man.
I'm only going to buy alligator shit anymore.
I buy like alligators so I buy like alligator skin things.
When I was a little kid an alligator he displayed his dog and I'll never forget
that I lived there.
I lived in Gainesville Florida and there was a place called Lake Alice and
there's alligators.
You see him all the time.
And I didn't think nothing of it because nobody was scared until one of them at
this lady's dog I was like Oh you motherfucker
but when you watch these people on these shows these these alligator hunting
shows first of all you realize how many fucking alligators there are because
they're killing a shitload of them.
You know they have like a tag that they can fill.
I don't remember what the guy was saying but it was like Oh.
I think it was like 500 or something.
Let's find out.
Alligator tag limits in Florida.
We didn't talk.
How was it being in Texas during all that fucking bomb shit and raised
fertilizer things and crazy crazy.
We we we will miss the fertilizer thing cause I was only there for one day but
that the bomb shit all of it is just the whole thing is when it was something
like that happens.
It's so fuckin scary you know Katie waitress Katie from the Comedy Store.
Yeah.
Her cousin's like look at this photo right here.
Here's the terrorist guy right here in the hat.
This is him dropping off the bomb.
Yeah.
Because this is the restaurant and he's walking the opposite way to the he must
just dropped it off right there right.
Here's supposedly the kid that died.
Oh God.
Here's her cousins all right over here and they all lost their limbs.
And so they're gonna have like a benefit show soon but that's just a crazy
picture though because it has it all and all together.
What the fuck man.
No one knows what any motive yet.
Where we're at now in the news.
It's all purely speculation because the brother's dead and the youngest brother
is he got shot in the throat Apparently kneeling ways communicating is writing
things down.
Here's something I just understand.
And of course there's a million people online that are shouting out false flag
false flag the government trying to take out our weapons away and tight down
security and that's why that's why this is happening.
Did you read the kid's Twitter like I stayed up all night.
Sure yeah.
Twitter was spooky.
I didn't see it.
Yeah.
His to his Twitter was really spooky it was weird.
It seemed normal day but then he would throw in like little things like fuck the
police and then or something like Mohammed something.
Well I think if you're going to paraphrase a guy he's a fucking murder or the
least he could do is go to his Twitter page you lazy and actually read the
night.
I'm not my greatest guy.
That's what he said.
That was one of his tweets.
Yeah.
He goes on mostly kind of a stress free guy.
This is after he had blown people up.
Yeah allegedly.
Of course this is the kid that survived the one that's dead.
There's all these disputes about what happened to him.
Some people are saying the cops ran over him.
He's saying his brother ran over him
the whole thing sounds like and people are crying out conspiracy.
One thing you have to realize about information whenever there's a tragedy or
whenever there's anything that's like really scary like this you know there's a
terrorist bombing.
It's people panic and you get a whole bunch different versions of the truth.
And it's not a conspiracy a lot of times it's just.
No one knows what the fuck is going on.
Everybody's terrified and stories spread very quickly like they thought at one
point in time that one of the suspects was a missing University student from
Brown.
And he was believes an Indian young man and his family had been looking for him
for like a month and they distributed this video and people are saying this is
one of the suspects.
This is really what happened.
You become like a jihadist and left.
But that wasn't true at all.
By the morning we found out it was a totally different person.
So this is not.
This isn't like a conspiracy to like hide that information.
And I think that's really important when when people are looking at events like
this we'll wait till the dust settles don't just start fucking calling out
conspiracy and calling out red flags and false flags saying that it's some you
know nefarious thing going on.
Whatever it is is horrific.
But jumping on the immediate conspiracy bandwagon is like Man that is one of the
worst things for the cause of questioning things.
And if you ever wanted to be a good disinformation agent what you do is the
moment that anything happens.
Start yelling and screaming it's a conspiracy and expose every single aspect of
it.
That you you feel is corrupt.
That would be the best way for the government to protect themselves from any
thoughts of being labeled you know as being a part of a conspiracy because
there's so many nutty people that do that with every single event that it's like
they've cried wolf you know.
Yeah
I was so nervous with Greg Fitzsimmons that night because he was actually down
there doing shows and I texted him and he said that the shows were canceled he
uses in his bed watching movies.
Yeah shows your accounts.
Oh that one night don't know if it was.
Was it Friday night.
That was he flew all the way down there.
Yeah that was it was crazy man.
Friday night I was what was even crazier is how horrible CNN was.
There were like an hour and a half behind but then you'd like Look was it has to
have Watertown that jam gave me.
It was just like guys throwing grenades.
This happening this happened like it was so insane reading that.
And it was also.
It was amazing how censored everything was or delayed it was on the news.
It's like you think you know that shit's you know people are getting grenades
thrown and that would be on the news immediately you know.
But they were just like talking like oh you know we're still looking for this
guy.
It's incredible everybody's a witness now and everybody's a cameraman now.
Like what.
What's happening is you know people on the streets can beat the news.
Yeah because they're right there too.
You also don't get a filter meaning you don't get anyone correcting it either.
So it's interesting because you get you get instantaneous news but you don't get
it vetted.
No it doesn't.
People don't make sure that everything that's coming through is kosher.
Not to the news always get it gets it right.
They don't.
And I guess it's better to do it that way where it eventually sorts itself out
but the people that would step in and sabotage that process and create
disinformation like a government agency could be pretty fucking successful at
doing that I think and there's probably a bunch of people that are hired to do
that shit all the time.
I've been accused of it myself but I will tell you that is incorrect
and that I think like in those Starsky and Hutch movies like when someone would
say one or TV show or any any cop show these to have to remember in the old days
like someone would say if you're a copy of tell me like when someone's an
undercover cop.
Oh yeah and mirrors like a secret password.
Yeah.
You got to ask him Are you a cop.
I think Oh shit.
Yeah I'm a cop.
Yeah and I'm too smart for you Jack.
You can't buy this heroin.
You know there was like some magic word I think that was a creation of fiction.
Yeah yeah I think they changed that.
Yeah
but people always thought that.
But you know that's that's probably some disinformation the cops put out there.
There was an accusation recently that the DEA put out a false paper about them
not being able to track people by using a message because I messages over the
Internet.
And so there was like an article like and I'm like a tech site like if you're
planning to sell drugs like do it through I message why.
Because the DEA says it can't read it.
And then you know the DEA is pressuring Apple but it turned out that was fake.
There's like the DEA made that just get a bunch of assholes that are drug
dealers you know your dog just I message me I don't know what accent that is if
that's your nationality.
I apologize.
It was just a spur of the moment thing.
I mean no disrespect but you know like the DEA made a they put out fake news to
trick dummies into using a message to sell drugs.
It's a good idea.
It is it's very crafty but it's one of those things where it gets to the point
of you know when that's not total entrapment.
That's just lying.
But what happens when you have undercover people when you have undercover people
involved those undercover people sell you coke and then you arrest them.
That's crazy.
You know why it's crazy because there's no real Coke.
OK.
You're not selling coke you're arresting them.
So you're saying that they wanted to buy coke but you weren't even really
selling coke.
You just got them to act through the moments to get point and get out and talk
through it.
There was no coke to buy.
There's no crime to commit.
They might have thought they were going to commit a crime but there was no real
Coke.
They're not really buying anything.
Not really selling anything.
There was no real transaction to fake transaction.
You're playing make believe.
And that's fucked up because you're also trying to arrest people because the
more b b arrest the better your career looks.
So it becomes a quantifiable thing so you can talk someone into doing something
illegal and then arrest them.
And then it helps you.
But that's crazy because people talk people in the suck their dick.
People talk people into doing all sorts of stupid shit they didn't really want
to do.
They just did because they got persuaded people could be persuasive.
So if you're some crazy sociopathic Fuck that just so happens to be an
undercover cop and you want to talk people into doing shit for you so you can
arrest them.
We need to put you in a cage OK.
You you crazy fuck yeah.
Tony.
Yeah.
You saying I'm an undercover cop.
No.
How do you guys find out about that.
Well the Internet is one of the first we had to vet it but we just figured we'd
run it by first.
See how you reacted.
Well you know I have to tell you once you bring it up it's true.
I'm an undercover cop.
You know it's just the whole idea that they can pretend to buy drugs from you
and then arrest you.
It's like what are you doing with it.
Why did you go get it.
Stop.
Stop that.
You're selling fake drugs you're buying fakes drugs.
Stop it.
Just cut the shit.
Stop trying to trick people.
OK.
Easy catch me.
Don't stop playing games pretending you're criminals.
If you catch me don't.
Jesus Christ can we be everybody be superhero superheroes dump tend to be
undercover drug lords and sell your fucking illegal guns then arrest you.
Yeah I think with the drugs it's good.
I think they should keep you on that predator thing now the drone.
No.
Get those guys to catch a predator like bust and the guys that are trying to
hook up with kids and stuff.
Oh yeah.
That's different.
Predator drones a couple of kids.
Yeah.
But even that.
You know what.
Let's talk about that is like what have you got like a really weak dude.
And he's a pedophile and he's gone through like you know counselling and he's
got like all this you know shit that's heavy in his head but he's gonna figure
out a way to never abuse again like he got out of jail and he's trying to go
through counselling he's trying to straighten himself out and then along comes
the fucking to catch a predator show and they just troll his ass off.
I don't know how they get people to get into their site and chat with them.
Shit like I don't know what those people say back.
I don't know what they get to say back but.
Well sometimes you know they have the kid being extra teasing it is sort of like
Hey there's a party plugged up I'm having a party and making cookies.
Can you bring some sweet tea.
Although a sweet tea house was sweet to southern most sweet tea.
Me too I suck dick.
There's there's there's some cookies on the table I'll be right up and then
that.
What's his name.
Chris Hansen.
Powerful Chris Hansen.
How many crazy people that guy I met.
Do they still do that or not show.
I don't think so.
I think they got in trouble I think.
I don't see a lot of what they did.
First of all I think you have to get people to sign releases to air that stuff.
I don't know how they got anybody to sign a release.
I mean I haven't really considered news.
Maybe it's like look I don't know.
I mean how did they do that.
If you're audibly they probably cover their costs their lawyers everything.
What if they really.
Oh yeah.
Because it's worth it to them to have a helmet.
We're just totally speculating all of and you know better than anyone.
So why don't we look that up real quick.
Let's see how to catch a predator.
Many thanks to Google.
How did you catch a predator.
Get them sign waivers.
Sure.
Watch what what you Google man.
You don't want that in your right.
Yeah no kidding right.
Hey what was up with you in the Google glasses man.
I saw.
I'll tell you.
Just call me honey.
Honey honey sweetie pie.
How did kids get them to sign waivers
yeah you could get in trouble for like looking too much into Catch predator like
what he tried to avoid being busted.
You know I was thinking about that the other day like how do you even know
what's going on if you can't do certain things like I was thinking of looking up
like how to make a bomb.
Just to see if that's out there.
Like nobody knows if that's out there.
If you don't google it and everybody's afraid to google it.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
Did you do it.
No I didn't.
I don't want anything to happen.
Which is why I think I left an impression.
You know something.
I was curious about.
I wish there was a thing you could google where it's like I don't know.
I just don't get it but it seems like any crazy kid.
I don't know
the Internet's power.
The scariest thing about shows like catch predator is you see that these guys
are like broken you know you see they're like horrified when they get caught.
You see they know that it's fucked up.
It's not like these remorseless cold insensitive unfeeling you know they're not
scared when they get caught these guys fall apart.
You see they're horrified at who they are.
It's really it's scary scary to say because it's like a glimpse into madness.
You know that guy Chris Hansen.
I guarantee you.
Now this sounds like some hippie bullshit but being around people that are that
fucked up on a regular basis and broadcasting them and paying your bills based
on broadcasting them and all and I mean like under the guise I guess you're
pulling these people off the street and that's always a good thing.
Well you know what happened to him right.
What was it.
Was that he got caught cheating on his wife or something I got some big media
thing.
Then he got investigated with a camera.
He was out with another bomb.
Me.
Look I don't know what the fuck the guy's marriage was like.
You know I don't want to.
Crack on the guy for that.
I think there's a big difference between that.
And you know of course you know some.
Pocket child some consensual.
Shit he did with Secretary whoever.
That freak is.
Oh I hate him for that but being around all those people that were kid fuckers
man.
That's gonna wear on your soul that's going to wear in your soul did you even
see these people over and over again and being in their presence when you know
most of them are probably I mean I guess this isn't their first time I would I
would assume this isn't the first time they probably already had sex with young
kids or any so you watch.
It's just it's it's just it's really it's gonna be a really depressing view of
the world and it's only so many different things you can expose yourself to in a
24 hour time period and you got you know 365 of those 24 hour time periods in a
year and you got a hundred of those years if you keep your shit together but
most likely no.
And you're gonna spend time hanging around pedophiles all the time.
And it's one thing if you're a guy and that's your job pull them off the street.
But I don't I'm not exactly sure what good it does making a show out of that.
You know I mean except scare the fuck out of everybody and make us aware.
But I feel like you know not that I mind them being outed because it's such a
heinous crime against humanity.
But
man it seems like a fucked up thing to broadcast.
You know it's like what do we want to concentrate on.
It's one thing to like work on cleaning that up but as a piece of entertainment
programming you're gonna you're going to concentrate on someone who wants to
victimize children and you're just gonna focus on that a lot.
I think it was a hit because you know they're the ultimate bad guys.
Well you know you're looking at the villain of all villains right.
No matter how fucked up your own life is right.
Right.
Yeah.
Nobody's lower than a child molester.
Everybody can go that fuckin piece of shit that fuckin p has to be on the couch
picking your fat toes.
Smoking a cigarette.
You see they're just picking dry skin and your toes and just drop it on the
floor of this motherfucker.
That piece of shit I hope he writes I hope he writes in jail.
Death is too good for him.
I hope he rot in jail.
You know what they do to child molesters.
They get him in their persons fucking wretched stupid human being is barely an
ape.
They get the shit on this child molester and feel better.
That voice grosses me out the bastard later.
I feel bad I and do it from Boston and Boston is in a bad position right now.
Oh just don't you know this Boston thing.
When one of the things that is fascinating is that they like there was a thing
about how they weren't going to read him his rights and then
this you know this thing about how whether or not they were going to try him as
an enemy combatant or try him as a civilian.
It's really fascinating that that's becoming like a real issue.
You know the way they decide to approach it like is this guy an American that
we're gonna try as an American you know or someone who lets someone when someone
commits any form of terrorism.
Are they are they instantly just out of the club.
Or do we try him as one of us you know.
Is it or is it a war thing.
Are we at war.
How we gonna how we're going to go forward in this
Yeah it's interesting.
It's once it's interesting the way we label things.
You know and it's interesting.
OK.
Any conspiracy theory aside that all these nutty ideas that are floating around.
One thing we know for sure
there was bombs that a person put in place that killed a bunch of people that
didn't do anything wrong.
And we have to figure out how the fuck that happens and I know that sounds super
simplistic but as a human as a species that's evolving clearly as we were
talking about the Mongols earlier and like what they used to do a thousand years
ago like our most heinous acts pale in comparison to those of our ancestors.
But when something like this happens you realize that people are still capable
of such embarrassing ruthless stupidity arrogance and just horrific
insensitivity towards their fellow man.
The idea that you could just take a bunch of people you don't know and kill them
and maim home and just you just were in the wrong spot at the wrong time and I
got a message and there's only one thing that gets people to do that Fox by the
way and that's an ideology right.
It could either be a religion or could be a cult.
Or it can be you know some group that you belong to that sworn allegiance to a
certain code or set of rules.
But that's the only way you get people to do shit like that if they don't have
an ideology.
They just don't do that.
Doesn't make sense.
There's no evolutionary benefit to doing that other than pleasing a group of
other like minded psychopaths someone you have to be
amongst a group of people that have very specific beliefs that above all else
take precedent.
So that you're willing to put your humanity aside for your crazy beliefs in a
completely irrational display of destructive power and that you can kill
innocents.
That only comes from ideology and we get really lost.
When we start talking about religious freedom and religion and you know an
atheists are guilty of this just as much as really religious people are because
whether you call it being a Muslim whether you call it being a Buddhist whether
you call it being a vegan whether you call it being a Christian whether you call
it being a Republican whether you call it being a Democrat whether you call it
being a progressive when you lock yourself in anything you become a part of
something that's almost been decided for you.
You you you you you lock into a pre arranged set of opinions on things and some
of them are bat shit fucking crazy and just like the Mongols got a hundred
thousand mother fuckers to roam across Russia and Europe and China and slaughter
millions of people.
You can't do that unless you've got a cause you can't do that unless you're part
of a group.
You can't do that unless your group is separate from the other groups.
And the only way that ever works is someone's got to talk you into that shit.
You've got to be a part of something.
And with this kid apparently was or he was you know the one they're saying did
it he was a pretty radical religious young man.
Now whether or not that's true.
Who knows science.
It has to be it seems to be the one thing that all these people have in common.
Yeah well I think the false flag people are thinking that like somebody gave
them all this stuff and that they were talked into doing it and then it was a
plan to erode civil liberties that they would sacrifice a few Americans and
clamp down on laws.
And this is this really is classically what military leaders have been doing
since the beginning of time.
You know like we're talking about armies in the past would actually sacrifice
soldiers and slaughter them so that the rest of the people could eat you know
they would cannibalize themselves.
That was they.
They had to talk somebody into doing something like that.
You know I mean
the first time somebody says that's super awkward Yeah.
It's fuckin you know it's hard to believe that in this day and age with the like
if you look at like how amazing humans are capable of being you know.
Like here's a perfect example Oprah now I know Brian doesn't like my love for
Oprah.
I love that you're I Oprah I think it's Brian.
He goofs on me but it's an honest appreciation for what she does because Oprah
like you know I have a friend who worked for and is like man she's like super
yuppie bitch.
Barely an hour and how the fuck are you going to try to be a standup comedian
you can't even go two hours without paying.
My friend was like he worked for and he was like pow.
She's like intense you know.
You know she's like really.
She has an idea what she wants and she gets done and you know he was like I
think he's been intimidated by too because he was working for but like stop and
think about how much nice that lady does like that lady is like so nice.
All those women that come to her show they feel great.
Everybody leaves positive.
I was reading this thing the other day on negative energy and that there was
some sort of a study that actually showed that negative energy is contagious.
If you find out you know if you if you're hanging around people that are
negative it doesn't just affect you when you communicate with them and becomes a
part of the way you communicate as well.
It becomes contagious and one like super aggressive contagious negative person
can actually infect like a company.
I think that's why it's important that I mean companies have been really focused
on that.
I think ones that are really aware of the social structure within the
organization they want to make sure that you don't get like a really negative
Downer type person in any sort of a role because if you get them you know that
they can really infect.
Like if they're especially if you had some guy like you work on a big project
you got some one guy who's leading and he's a douche bag and everybody shows up
work like oh it's there's very few things in life worse than being stuck like
working in a job it sucks with a boss who's an asshole.
Right.
Why do why are all bosses mostly assholes to me making my list.
I look back at all the jobs I've ever had you know and it's the majority like
they were always the assholes they were never the people you hung out with or
wanted to hang out with you know they're always there I was always a terrible
employee.
So I think anytime a boss got mad at me I totally deserved it.
There was a shitty.
I did a shit job mowing lawns when I was a you know a lot landscaper.
I remember the guy hired me to fuckin scalped this law and I did not work a lot
more.
I lied just like you get the job like my friend did.
And you said you could do it easy so often it's not hard but it was hard.
The first time I did it was kind of hard to figure out.
These are old shitty lawnmowers you know and I sculpt the shit out his lawn.
You fucking hate most don't you hate it.
That used to be torture.
It's not it's it's not easy.
Oh yeah but when I was in high school my friend Chris he one of the things about
Boston about growing up in Boston.
Boston is like a really in G.
They have a lot of ingenuity.
There's a lot of like people get shit done.
So like it's a strong work ethic.
They're like clearly way stronger work ethic than I ever experienced here in
California.
Like people are so used to getting up in the morning shoveling their car out
from the snow they're used to shit like it's a different kind of like there's a
different kind of like mentality there.
You know if you grow up there you go and figure out what we're talking about.
I had an example where we talked about just before that Boston yes fuck
I had a point and I completely lost it and trying to figure out why it is
S.A.
after burying it.
I didn't.
I took it but not until right before the show.
Fuck mowing lawns.
Oprah.
No no no I was passed over dude.
It was the the mowing lawns things about oh my friend Chris.
Okay.
When I was in high school this is what it was when everybody else was like you
know I had a job like Poppa Gino's and shit I was like making spaghetti and I
was like pretty easy boring job.
This kid had a lawn mower empire.
He had a landscaping empire.
He had a brand new car.
He had people working for him.
He had lawns that were going while he was at school.
He had guys working farm.
They were cutting lawns wise at school and he would come home and he would go
and work till nighttime and they'd show up for work the next day.
He always have new sneakers on.
He was like a grown man.
By the time we were 17 this fucking kid I had never been around more people.
That made me feel like a lazy bitch.
There was so many dudes like my friend Jimmy that I used to love Jimmy to tell
yo this guy.
Like he had from the time he was in high school he had his own electrical
business.
He worked for a guy for a little while.
Started doing work on the same time he got at a high school just got his own
business bus and asked 10 12 hours a day drive it all out ran like a maniac.
It was you while you're around people like that like you you develop that sort
of you know that sort of tenacity that exists.
Like not a lot of spots in this country you know.
And I think that dealing with like environmental conditions there's something
about that.
It's why people from New York tend to be funnier.
You know people from Boston tend to be funnier because they're dealing with so
much bullshit all the time.
Definitely and controls.
I definitely think where you're coming up with that raised has a lot to do with
that type of crazy factor of your communication skills really.
I think it's down to like you know small talk if it's the city that you're
raised in.
It rains a lot.
You're going to end up having to talk with your friends more or if it snows a
lot if it rains a lot if it's a windy city.
Things like that.
It's true.
And I think to be indoors or really apply.
Yeah.
Socially for sure.
Right yeah.
In California you could sleep outside and live right.
I drank I drank.
Tom Hardy didn't talk on the porch was smoking cigarettes.
That's a Don't you think that Ohio of today growing up in the same place where
you grew up would be very different because the Internet because kids growing up
with the Internet be a lot more tolerable.
That's for sure.
Yeah right.
Yeah.
That's a totally different world now.
The whole world also got lights turned on everywhere lights turned on and the
news started showing up all the information started flowing whereas before you
relied on local newspapers and fuckin TV news.
Bitch how the fuck did you know what was going on anybody know what was going on
then man.
How did anybody know.
So I think they're saying that there's like certain laws that apply to
pedophiles.
That's why these guys were allowed to be put on that show.
And there's a reason why they quit.
The guy killed himself while filming it.
One of the suspects somebody tweeted.
Well if they were being honest when they say good riddance.
See you next week.
Yeah.
Show it.
I mean are they trying to get rid of predators and trying to catch him.
It's not.
It's bad if they commit suicide.
Well we're all God's creatures even the ones that fuck kids.
What I mean what is that.
That's ridiculous.
Well they got sued for one hundred and five million dollars.
Why don't they just come clean and give the guys have gone on the show and go
listen sir there's a bullet in that gun put it up to your head.
Fuck this trial.
And that would be we'll pay for your funeral.
Well you know they'd be the most watched reality.
And then as soon as he blows his brains I go sigh.
Film it.
Get a close up on him or we're out.
Get out of there.
Just leave him there.
Put it on TV no one's gonna know.
What are they gonna do.
They are the cops gonna sue NBC.
They're gonna bring him in for questioning.
Look you saw what happened.
God fucks kids we gave him a gun.
Okay we're cool.
We're good here right here.
Would that be illegal I would say yes especially if the guy didn't have a gun
permit.
Yeah I guess it really depends on the gun law.
Yeah well maybe you could do it if you gave me a gun and said Whatever you do do
not shoot yourself in the head right now on TV.
You will smile a wink huh.
There was this weird comic at the at the store last night.
Do you remember this Tony.
There was some Norwegian comic that I did something about Michael Jackson or
something.
But he had this huge Wikipedia that just goes off about how brilliant this guy
is and how much money how did he write his own Wikipedia is with me.
But I mean he is connected to it like a lot of these TV shows and stuff.
But anyways his wife comes up to me goes Hey Fat Man come you fat man.
And I was right in front of my target.
And she was trying to tell me that she wanted that.
That he has a nice house up here and he pretty much she was trying to get me to
come back to them how their house for an origin for what it seemed like and she
wanted you.
Well it's probably what they feel like Hollywood's about right.
Yeah.
And he's like if I am going to make it here you have to give up the pussy.
Listen we need orgies all of the time.
Norway only way to make it as comedians so weird.
Yeah that's that's a pretty odd story there fellow.
And then and then she's showing me these photos and her phone.
She's like look at the parties we have.
And it's just like her and this other girl like know women she's a comedian.
No no no she's the wife of the one she's just like going around the whole place
like bragging about her husband how many million.
Yeah she was she was very cute but this guy looked like a bear and you know he's
a bigger guy with a suit that's like four sizes too small we're probably both
CIA guys you got slowly worked there is slowly gonna make it into the
organization.
DAVE There were looking into this whole death squad thing.
You know like with his death squad we have to worry about them.
We'll see.
See you you're the guy that they wanted to take up there and show them.
Yeah.
Sure.
You're going to drug you and hit you with some fucking some hypnosis.
Europeans just they just don't have like normal sex.
He's going to be some Manchurian Candidate type 2 that's going to happen.
CIA do is going to drop a nano pill in his drink.
That's silly bitch.
He'll be hammered.
He'll drink anything to send his way.
You know with all the waiters that lady that drives around in that pink Corvette
that's all yesterday.
This was my night Yes sir excuse me last week.
This was my point that I see her maybe once a week and it's always random places
like I'll see her in Hollywood once I hear a lot around here.
But like that you just need to tell people what she is.
She used to be like a rich wife I guess that would post photos or these
billboards like all over.
Just kind of promoting her and I don't think she really had.
Well that's one way to describe.
Yeah.
I don't think she really had anything going.
She just had a lot of money to play with and so she pretty much made her seem
like she was a big deal when she really wasn't used as a rich wife.
Yeah well the billboards were these giant billboards.
See Angelina on them in like big letters like whoa it's Angelina.
And she's this really pale lady with giant tits.
Yeah and she looks a little odd like she looks like.
Like really like photo shopped.
Like really like brightly lit like it's really hard to discern like key features
because she's apparently she's very old.
And when I came to L.A.
in 94 she had big billboards all around town.
Like several of them that said Angelina it was just her and then her
management's number.
It was her in her underwear.
It was really high.
Yeah it was kind of crazy because you know she was.
She had a really nice body I guess.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
I do that.
Yeah.
And that's like.
What's her face.
Dolly Parton.
Yeah.
But by the time she was doing this I mean who knows how old she was in that
picture but the the one that you see today bears no resemblance.
Yeah.
I had no idea who she was.
And we were shooting something at Hollywood Highland one night and that crazy
like area and all of a sudden she pulls up and people were like Oh my God
there's Angelina.
And it took I had no idea who this was and it took it like four people 20
minutes to be able to explain to me what the big thing was there.
Well I think she's in L.A.
she's like a..
Like an icon.
Yeah she's probably 60 years old at least.
She still dresses like she's like 75.
I've seen her several.
I wonder what she wanted if she wanted to be an actress or like what.
Oh that's a good question.
Interesting marketing campaign.
But what's really weird is is that how much I sear and jump in.
That's like one of the only cars where you're like Oh that's her.
That's her.
Like how many times you actually drive by people you probably know right and
drive around the same cars.
It's just so weird how small Los Angeles actually is.
At that point you will in that sense and you know it's also like the spots that
she hits the spots you're at like I said I just saw the coffee being there.
That's what she looks like now.
Yeah yeah yeah man.
All right.
I'm sure she's a nice lady.
I mean you know I don't know hate but you wouldn't do that.
No I mean look man.
Nothing wrong with being that you know that's who she is she's fabulous.
Let her go get it.
Fuck this look.
Look that Brian put that away
all the way.
She's your grandmother man.
Show some respect.
I don't know if she's a mother or a grandmother but you know that that whole
wanting to be famous thing is a strange thing.
She was like one of the original reality stars.
She created her own reality show by just putting up billboards.
A reality show became her life you know no one was filming it but her life was a
reality show.
You know I know she was I knew she was a couple of years after living here.
So I've known who she was since 96 ish 97 ish.
Wow.
I remember when she pulled up she had her face covered with like some kind of
like one of those Asian aliens.
Yeah and shoot.
She was mysterious.
Yeah well
yeah.
That's uh that's a strange strange world we live in my friends man.
If I was a porn star hot chick porn star I would buy a pink Corvette and be her
new competition.
I'd be so rude.
You can call yourself Anzalone.
Yeah or Angelina.
That's a good idea though because I mean that's how she got her attention to
seeing that you know pink Corvette the money girl Angelina maybe you could have
like your whole thing was about like how you get a rich husband who allows you
to freelance in your porn career and that you know that will be the whole thing.
So the husband has no idea what's going on he comes home.
What is happening in here.
Who are these guys.
And you explain while they were tag team and you I'm got to say you know it was
all so I could get better with you honey
I just.
They're they're not tag team me.
They're teaching me this is it's very controversial.
I should been.
Not going anywhere.
Have you ever been with a girl that you're just completely haunted about like
that you think about like even after it happened it was like Why the fuck did I
do that.
That's part of being truck son.
That's a whole part of being drunk.
That's a beauty of life.
If you didn't have those stories then you wouldn't have those awkward moments.
And if you didn't have those awkward moments you wouldn't have some really
hilarious shit to talk about when everyone else is drunk as well.
I can understand what you're saying here.
That's what drunks have the best stories.
The being drunk drunk stories when they could just really cut loose and be free
and not worried about it.
I have friends from back in the Boston days of the best stories when they're
drunk and then somewhere along the line those folks become alcoholics anonymous
people and all the stories stop.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm going to start getting into alcoholics anonymous soon.
Speaking at the Comedy Store.
Going at comedy clubs so much you just have to fucking during me and Tony battle
with this almost every single night where we're like have you got a drink.
Yeah.
Because you know I mean it's just you know what's interesting about you know
it's like either the night's going great and you want to drink to celebrate or
it's a fucking boring night.
You want to drink to have more fun.
It's like there's never ever a time where I'm just like in the middle like you
know.
I just said yeah we're going to do it every night.
Have a show though man it really can wear on you.
Well you know I'm very lucky because on my end of it I'll sometimes only have a
half a drink or one drink because I'm very little and I'm very reactive.
And so how many beers does it take to get you fucked up.
Two and a half probably.
Yeah two and a half beers and fucked up.
Three I'm fucked up.
Great.
Yeah.
Three and I just decide to tell a story that I wasn't sure if I was gonna tell.
Yeah I normally don't get to my third during Ken till pretty late.
Oh really that's funny.
Yeah that's weird.
How much you weigh.
Probably about 127 right around there.
And if you think about a beer is what a pound
right.
Yeah I guess so.
I'd say subtle of Jack Daniels fucks me up essentially you get to like one
percent of your body weight fairly quickly 1 percent by weight in beer.
Oh that's interesting.
Yeah.
Would you say what about Jack Daniels.
I've gotten to the point where I think one bottle of Jack Daniels would fuck me
shut up son you fucking start slurring when you open the cap.
Larry slurring in and then alive.
Sometimes I feel like I'm talking about like bleeding from the liver until I
expire.
Yeah it's interesting that no one's figured out a way to create the effect of
alcohol without the horrific effects to your fucking body.
Well gee you know my way works.
You could just get down to one hundred and twenty seven and just sip on a drink
all night long.
Feel great or black out every night because you keep forgetting nearly one sex
sounds now right.
Like you imagine it like a guy like Tate would take could.
Well he doesn't drink but in his prime.
Big guy you know the guys can put away more like Joey.
Joey could put away some fuckin booze at the wedding.
Joey
Joey barely ever drinks but when he does he always gets the most.
He said so cute that you'll get like I got an orange cream sickle.
He was a good man.
That's why you know people like pina coladas and shit.
Yeah yeah.
Fucked up and some folks only allow them that on when they're on vacation.
But men.
Well when men are drinking they weren't manly shit.
They want something that is mixing up.
Oh yeah right.
Talking about here's one drink right now.
I have a long night of drinking.
Don't be a pussy.
You're saying you rather drink with them than drink with us.
No I mean how would you have you.
How dare you let me know what you have because I'm pretty hung over right now.
Well I'm about to go watch a fucking UFO documentary.
So I'm fixing you're fucked up if only I can watch today.
I'm not really big on watching UFO documentaries while sober there's a spray
something's gonna go wrong.
This jam van just showed me there's a spray that gets you instantly drunk for a
few seconds.
Well that sounds awesome.
Seems super healthy.
You should give give that to yourself right before you leave the house.
How long does it last.
It doesn't say just a few 5 seconds.
Is it like some limpets type shit.
Yes.
No.
I don't know what it is.
It's one spray releases.
Point 0 0 7 5 0 0
0 gets you drunk legally 0 legally drunk.
How would you show me that they got some sportscaster some sportscaster got
pulled over for.
Is it Al Michaels.
I got pulled over and he was on the limit.
It was absent at the limit 0 8 and 0 9.
What happens then when you're out.
Here's a link.
Don't you first have to do the drug test.
You know like you walk around like a buffoon and then if you fail that then you
have to do it.
He obviously I guess showed signs that he can't do.
You know balance on one foot.
You know so.
Well not necessarily.
They might have just asked him and he said he would take the test cause you only
had one drink.
That's what he's saying.
Saying he only had one drink.
I think that I read that note.
You know what.
That's what the I'm sorry.
That's what Reese Witherspoon's husband said.
You got the wrong drunk.
He said he only had one job but the Al Michaels guy he tested on the limit.
And he's a fuckin man's man.
He's a fuckin sportscaster.
He told me that guy doesn't know how to drive when he's a little tipsy.
He's an 0 8.
Let him go.
You pussy don't you appreciate a good game of hockey being called by the maestro
and he let him go.
It's not like you're letting go of criminal 0 8.
Not something pro drinker that's a pro socialized.
Like I've known him since he was a baby.
Yeah.
0 8.
The fuck out of here.
What a pussy society we have.
That's not drunk.
OK if he's drunk.
Yeah for sure.
Arrest him asshole.
That's ridiculous.
People driving around drunk are assholes but people driving around that are
barely buzzed at 0 8.
Come on.
How do I know that your body functions as good as mine does when I'm drunk.
How about that.
Your reaction time.
How good is your outlook.
How do I know you're not a dullard without with a slow right foot.
You just can't get to that burger on time.
You know maybe Al Michaels could still even eat whatever he is 70 and still do a
solid two step hits that break like a champ.
Not saying he should drive drunk.
I'm saying what's 0 8.
Looks like a drink right.
Yeah pretty close yeah.
I would like to see what a 0 8 guy looks like performing stuff.
You know I wouldn't like to see him go through that.
I would like to.
I'm sure he's always nowhere when he's calling the Super Bowl.
You know what I mean bright you know.
You know one that doesn't count though here's the thing though is the adrenaline
that you get when you get pulled over.
I would imagine that would have some sort of a recuperative effect.
Like if you're a little a little driving a little shitty cause you're kind of
hammered and you get pulled over and it might jolt you into a position where you
could possibly perform the test a little better than you could be but it's not
going to make you less drunk right.
So 0 8 is still in 0 8.
She blew it.
Yeah I think it's just entirely too low to blanket that that's considered a DUI.
Because I mean you know if you go out to dinner and you have a drink like a
margarita and a bartender like cause it's stronger than normal.
Are you saying that just having one margarita with dinner you should go to jail
and you know get all these things on your license that you think you know that
you're gonna run into a pile into a school of children.
Like I don't buy that.
I think that's I think that's it.
I don't know I'm not a big fan.
I think aging needs to change.
I think that's a dosage issue where you're talking about the dosage issue and
that they really should get in trouble if they're doing that.
I mean people don't want to get in trouble you go you go.
This proves the good the stiffest drinks.
You really should let people know what the fuck you serve them and if you're
serving them some margaritas It's got twice the alcohol in it you're trying to
get customers that way you could fuck somebody up if they know exactly how they
usually rocket you know they have this thing I'm good for one margarita and then
I back the fuck off and then I get home and I'm fine.
And then also the guys hand driving on.
He doesn't know what happens because you you say saying essentially like doubled
his dose.
Yeah I'm just saying it's way too low I think.
Yeah but not to you.
I guess I see your point.
Definitely.
But I'm not convinced.
I don't have any data I want to see a guy who's at a weight go through all that
shit.
Is it based on what percentage you are.
Your fine too.
You know I want to do it.
I want to.
I want not to get you guys together.
No.
No I don't want to.
That's one thing I've been really careful about my entire life.
I think it's really important to be safe when you're operating a vehicle.
I mean the idea that you would operate a vehicle with your body all fuck in half
there.
That's so scary to me it's so scary to be the driver it's so scary thinking that
so many people out there that are doing it.
It's so selfish and stupid but I think that I would like to find out what it
feels like to be at 0 8.
And do you know any of those tests any of those lean.
I wouldn't know.
What is it like if they say like you know I'm not gonna drive but get me to the
limit.
Give me a breathalyzer.
OK you're at 0 8 now.
Like whether it's three drinks or two drinks and now make me do your stuff.
I want to know what it feels like.
Buy you can buy a breathalyzer on Amazon you should do it.
I don't want to do it because I don't want to.
I definitely don't want to drive by but I would like to drive on a course I
would like to go on a course and see like get me to 0 9 and let me see what I
can do.
I think you're gonna be surprised how exactly normal you're gonna be feeling.
I wonder why I wonder because I've been drunk and as of you I wonder.
I wonder what it's like to do that.
Well I would but then again like telling people that 0 8 or 0 9 is the limit
means that's probably where most people who are not in the best shape or don't
have the best talents for alcohol where they start to falter.
So if you make it a public policy that's probably a good idea to do it on the
conservative side you know ethnic humor you had a fun funny thing was talking
about like it should really be based on your tolerance and they should you
should have like a license that indicate their tolerance but that shit changes
too.
Because dudes start falling apart.
Yeah.
You have to just take a license test Sara tolerance test once a year.
It's so incredibly irresponsible to tell people they can drink more.
Right.
You know they tell people that the legal limit as is that you could drink a
little more.
Fuck just fucking green light.
I love that.
Yeah and God dance like me boy.
I got tolerance like.
I mean think about like that my friend Justin.
Here's a perfect example.
You know my friend Justin said that seven foot tall did not find Justin's like a
legitimate giant.
He's enormous.
And if you go drink for drink with him you're gonna die.
If you're going to die you're not the same species as him.
He's a completely different human being.
So it's like a dog next to a cat.
It's not the same time.
Pretty sure it's Andre the Giant actually has a drinking record.
I'm serious.
I think he has some.
There's a drinking record I think it's a crazy night.
And lawyers.
Wow.
But he was you know he's like he's like seven foot something.
He was enormous.
Yeah.
There's been a few giants since then that gotten mixed martial arts.
This is Guy giant Silva.
He was like a legit giant.
And he fought in pride.
And then there's Antonio Big Foot Silva and that guy.
I think I'm seeing I think I'm saying giant silver I think that's his name.
If not I apologize.
It's a big giant go crazy shaggy hair.
And then there's another guy semi shell.
He's like seven feet tall.
I think he's just a huge guy.
I don't think he has gigantism I think he's just an enormous regular human but
you would just imagine a guy like conjure the giant those little tiny you ever
see a picture of a little tiny beer can in his hand.
Yeah.
To Tracy to trip he would hold a beer in his hand.
I was like you hold on when those little kids apple juices you know the ones
that come in lunchboxes.
Well this is that they estimated that he drank over 7000 calories every day and
booze alone.
I wouldn't do that.
Do they have the sat there the number with.
I know it's like a decisive thing.
Well I want to see the picture of his hand because it's so silly.
You know Rowdy Roddy Piper started coming by the comedy store a couple of years
ago and once in a while he'll swing in and he's friends with a few of us there.
And man he's so great at hanging out and telling stories.
And one of the stories that he told us was about Andre the Giant.
Somebody was guys you know because they did the road together for a decade or
right.
Right.
And he talks about how one time they were at a bar and there were these college
kids like you know fuck you Andre the Giant
that they're drinking beers at that one time a kid drinks a beer throws the
empty can at the back Andre the Giant said and he goes.
Don't do that again.
And then later on he takes an empty can and he throws it at the back onto the
giant's head and they do that and they all sure.
Oh my God.
And they all run outside.
Running away from Andre the Giant who got up and is now chasing them and they
all got in their car all at once but Andre caught up to the car before it drove
away and he just flipped.
He he picked up the coin as you hear the story.
Rowdy Roddy Piper.
Really.
Yeah.
It's got to be a true story too even if it's not.
Let's let him tell it.
Isn't that picture hilarious though him holding the beer can.
I mean it's like a little bait.
It's like you ever see like a little kids refrigerators that they would fake
refrigerator.
That's what looks like.
One hundred and nineteen beers in six hours.
God that's what they're trying.
Yeah that's what he drank.
Yeah yeah.
How big was that guy.
What was his height and weight
7 1 7 foot 1.
And he wasn't just tall.
He was enormous.
Oh yeah.
God damn between 6 and 7 5 and over 5 some between 6 7 7 5 and over 500 pounds.
And then I also saw some that's a very whole fucking they measure him right.
You know what the problem with that is wrestling they lie you know six foot
eleven 3000 pound twisted steel you know they lie just to make guys look bigger.
But that guy was like legitimately enormous like in a real wrestling match he
would beat everybody.
I also heard a thing that that big body slam that was like from the big wrestle
mania to where Hulk Hogan body slams the ultimate bad guy Andre the Giant.
Right.
And it's like you could tell Andre the Giant jumps into it with all his might
and Hogan's just trying to.
Yeah.
All he needs to do is go like that.
It's amazing that he can even hold them up.
And he said that when he did that he could feel every disc in his back just go
up up up up up up up up.
Hulk Hogan.
Yeah.
And then he laid down Andre the Giant and he was just so glad that that was the
end of the match because he he ruined his back.
Yeah.
His back is fucked up now right.
He's had surgery.
All these guys are.
Those guys are unbelievable warriors because they were doing it every night and
sold out arenas.
You don't realize.
Right.
They had to put on a show.
They were going non-stop.
And like even Piper just like six or seven months ago he was by the store.
He would come in like once in a while every few days for you know just then.
Anyway he could.
He kept going Oh my shoulder saw my shoulder so I'm going to the doctor on
Wednesday.
It's still worked out for four hours today.
Well my shoulder saw Hannah finding out that he had a technically broken his
neck.
A broken neck and the doctor's like it's not your shoulder it's your neck and
it's broken.
So it was like pinching a nerve and Ryder was hurting his shoulder right.
But he he's just.
These guys are so tough in real life.
That
is to hit on a sore shoulder.
Yeah.
What does people give a fuck about wrestling anymore.
Oh yeah they're still there.
It's still very popular.
Unbelievable.
I keep seeing like C.M.
Punk and all these people and all the pictures and been crazy is that you know
most people don't know this but like Monday night raw for example which is the
premiere weekly show someone's a wrestling fan.
Yeah but it's been number one on one.
It's held Monday nights forever.
Do you know this and why the fuck do you know this.
I said I'm saying let's go on.
When I was saying when I was a kid I was in a wrestling like that.
And then I grew up and go oh my gosh.
Yeah I can't believe you went there.
Me too and I still like wrestling I'm still has pubic hair.
Dude stop being an asshole.
I don't.
I haven't watched wrestling.
What you're doing is cyberbullying right now.
No I'm just I've been giving him a hard time because they all had like a
wrestling party and I was there wasn't we our buddy you got wrestling mania and
he has a giant screen and it's funny too.
You know we all do you guys take our clothes off.
Yes.
Right.
Did you reenact the moves with lube.
Yes.
Hey what do you think about this CSPAN thing.
The bill that passed the House it's fucked up crazy scary.
If you guys don't know about the House of Representatives passed Cisco which is
the Cyber Intelligence Sharing and Protection Act by a 288 to 127 vote and it's
the ideas supposedly that it's meant to enhance national security by
facilitating sharing of electronic information between like this quote between
say a private company and the government this is a story from media dot com and
the way they describe it is that if the government like say if a private company
in the government deemed threatening the bill's opponents maintain it will make
sharing of personal private information far too easy so I guess the idea is what
is it what is the main the main idea about behind this bill is that they're
going to be able to see every website you've ever visited every Web site will
have a bill to share the information of different people who have gone to them
that would just you know I have no idea what the exact specific thing is but
yeah it seems like that's what I was talking about.
But it isn't going to be vetoed by Obama.
I don't know because he didn't have but he didn't veto the NDAA.
You know I mean Obama is a hilarious kind of situation because he's super
intelligent he's half black he's you know from a single parent household but
he's still like votes just like the Republicans do.
He still does stuff that the Republicans do like it's really strange.
It's like if he was a white guy people would be fuckin furious if he was a white
guy of privileged background and he made the choices that he's made as far as
like bailing out the banks as far as passing the NDAA not vetoing in all these
different things that have happened the drones all these different things that
have happened while he was in office.
If he was a white guy of privilege he would be getting crucified.
It's fascinating.
It's almost like the perfect plan like if you were a military strategist and
you're trying to take over the company you would do it with a situation like
that you wouldn't just go get some super elite rich guy you'd get some guy who
you would associate automatically with progressive liberal sensibilities and
then you do all that creepy shit right under his nose.
It's really interesting.
His big slogan was change yeah.
And looking back on it now it's like well he changed a little you know drone
attacks went from 50 up to like 300 changed a lot in Pakistan.
It's not funny but fuck man.
I don't know it's uh it's it's just seems like it if if he really could change
things.
If you really could like influence this society and how is the time to do
something you know instead of just these speeches sort of reactionary speeches
dealing with each and every issue whether it's Sandy Hook or whether it's
whether it's this Boston thing like wonder what if anything could be done to
sort of enact a
a change in a culture a plea for for a change in a culture.
And if anybody could do that it's got to be the president.
You know and the president addresses.
He does these national speeches where he addresses policies and he addresses not
national affairs as far as security affairs and then threats and various things
along those lines.
But what this country's really fucking needs they need of a different not not a
different person but a different mantra.
We need a new way of looking at things.
We need a speech.
We need something that gets people believe and we need an I have a dream that I
have a dream Martin Luther King's speech to this day.
That shit resonates.
No one's doing the I Have A Dream today.
Everyone's doing the.
We're all gonna get along and change and hope and you know and make it more
affordable and healthcare for everyone.
And gay marriage.
But no one has a speech about uniting humanity and getting us to understand that
our lives really are truly only better when people around us lives are better as
well and that United there's enough resources for everybody there's enough love
everybody is enough nuff health for everybody.
There really is.
It's just the current system in the current ideology that we have is not based
on the reality that we're an expiring lifeform.
And then we have a temporary time here on this planet and to waste it not being
aware of the full reality of the situation is a shame and a guy like Obama has
the opportunity to do that but he doesn't ever say anything like that.
He never says anything that really inspires people to look at it in a completely
different way.
He never says anything like I think you have to.
If you're in a position to be the fucking President of the United States that's
a position with very few human beings ever get to reach.
I mean maybe he will when he's leaving.
Maybe we will once he leaves.
Maybe you can't when you're there.
I mean who knows.
I mean maybe it really is an incredibly restrictive environment.
And he has no room to free ball and no room to go outside of what they want him
to distribute as policy.
I don't know.
Mean I don't know what the fuck the situation's like but if this world ever
needed someone to speak up and someone to just make some fucking sense someone
to make some sense and not talk politics you know not talk religion just talk
humanity not talk nationalistic not talk conflict just make some sense.
Well I guess this is the you know this the same bill was vetoed last year by the
White House and it looks like you know it just it's one of those things that's
just poorly written and everyone knows that type thing.
So so is the India.
Unfortunately pass really hard through Congress.
The thing is it didn't pass as hard in Congress the first time.
Well I think that I read something about it this morning.
A lot of the way the government set up and I'm obviously not an expert on
government but I know that a lot of the the way it's set up is that you know we
have representatives and you know we can't all be there while policy is being
dictated so our representatives go there and they make sure that everything
represents their constituents but clearly a better way to do all that is the
internet.
If anybody had to be phased out.
Oh it's the majority of politicians they're involved in making laws.
You could face those guys can get all new jobs you know.
Have you seen House of Cards.
No.
She is awesome.
This show shows you what's actually happening in Washington following a real TV
show.
Oh somebody made up.
Oh it's unbelievable.
No shows you.
You realize what they're what they're dealing with.
What they're actually doing and it's all just it's.
Is it awesome.
It's all just deals.
The show's unbelievable I mean Kevin Spacey already is a bad mother breaks the
third wall or whatever and just start flicking at the camera telling you what
he's thinking in the middle of scenes.
It's pretty.
It's really great.
Oh it's the there's everyone else freeze in the background freeze like they're
playing the game sort of pretty much.
There's
still still the you know they blur out but then it's just him just know it'll be
a cross meeting table from somebody like here's what I'm about to do and they
don't know it but here's how I'm going to do it.
Watch this.
Oh and it's amazing it's really just politicking.
You learn a lot about you know even show business and networking overall from
how these politicians operate because that's all that they're doing is playing
gossip games and texting and it's a broken system and they're all criminals
keeping us from the Internet.
That's what it is.
They're trying to tighten down on this fuckin system and what they don't want to
do is admit that this could all be handled way better with voting online.
Let's do it that way.
Every person has an I.D.
every I.D.
is just like your fucking social security card.
Yet only do it once boom and you vote online.
Yep.
And when that happens that's when things get good.
You can't control that bitch.
You can't you can't control that.
They'll deal.
They'll never allow something like that.
They will fight it till death.
That literally might be where the revolution lies.
I is getting people to vote online because they would essentially be giving up
all of their tricks but they've been using over the past decades to manipulate
how ah ah ah.
People are picked how our presidents picked how laws are passed and all that
shit has been manipulated everything should be done the popular vote now.
Yeah.
Isn't it a fascinating idea that there would so try hard.
They would try so fucking hard to avoid.
Yeah that would be like a real tipping point.
This country will really realize we're being run by vampires.
Oh yeah.
Like how quickly they would fuckin shriek into the dark corners of the room when
you open the drapes and take a good look at the real scenario.
Then I try to like give the people what they want.
They're trying to profit off the current system.
The current corrupt system as in place got.
Tony you need to write your clean young man you can run for president.
You're very likeable could probably pull it off.
You think you could.
There was a period of time when I was a kid and I wanted to but you wanted to be
president at one point.
Time for a little moment.
Did you fall on your head or something.
What made you want to be president.
How do you get sick.
We deliver now.
I thought it was just very very young.
I thought it was going.
Did you have the fever.
Yeah.
The president's fever.
He had the president's fever.
You know when we all go through that score and sixteen you're lying in your bed
dying.
Yeah I got obsessed with.
There was a period where as a kid I was obsessed with like the Declaration of
Independence and how it came to be in like a hole.
I read it.
I remember reading a whole book about John Hancock when I started practicing my
signature all the time.
I was obsessed with John and I thought that was so cool that this guy had the
balls to be like here you go here I am and I did this.
Who would be the first person to be president that doesn't have the fake
president voice who'll be the first person that just talks to everybody a person
who changes the world who doesn't have a way of speaking with long vague pauses
when I believe what I believe for you.
And for me and for our great nation is that we must unite.
Imagine if it is it's so bizarre that fucking guy was over your house bitch why
are you talking like that.
Why are you talking this fake stupid voice but you get away with that when it's
a big group of people and you're a politician.
We know that you're talking in the fake us most old school way possible.
You might as well be in the theater you dummy.
It might as well be in the theater back when they didn't have microphones when
they just have to shout out their stupid lines.
Imagine a strip club deejay being the president just shook up deejay with no
microphones coming up to the main stage.
It's time
and then a bunch of banjo players behind have the music because you don't have
electricity do they.
I country at a bomb threat.
I got more information or more evidence to the poor people that think that I'm
in league with the devil.
I wore this t shirt on Fox.
It was the Wild and Wonderful Whites of West Virginia.
They when I ordered the DVD they found out we talked about on the podcast so the
people that make it they sent me these cool T-shirts and one of them was that
famous picture of Nixon meeting Elvis leather shaking hands but they replaced
Elvis's head with Jessica White and Nixon with the devil himself and says like
the devil and so just go and I wore nuts on Fox and I got like a hundred tweets
go.
What the fuck are you wearing on TV.
I didn't even think about it but for a good portion of this knucklehead country.
If you have a shirt on that has a devil's face it says the devil like these
dummies actually think that you like you're you're down with the devil like the
devil and that's what that's where we draw the line in this kooky country even
even you know even religious people like you can say that you believe in God
you're allowed to say that you even want to say that God talk to me.
You know I saw a guy say that the other day didn't even bother me.
There was a guy that was in Austin Texas.
There was a guy that was at a red light.
He was begging.
He had a cardboard thing.
And the guy in the car rolled down the window said Hey man.
God just talk to me and told me I should give you this.
And he gave the guy 20 bucks.
That doesn't bother me but if the guys roll down that window it Hey man I was
just speaking to Satan and he thought you could use this to party with me.
You're not talking to Satan anybody believes in Satan as an asshole like you're
allowed to believe in God.
But if you say you believe in Satan everybody tells you to go fuck yourself.
You have to be like way deep in cuckoo for cocoa pops.
Oh you actually believe in Satan to believe in to believe in the bad guy.
Yeah.
Have you ever met someone who actually believed in Satan and you didn't know
that they believed in Satan until you got to know them.
I mean you know like shit I feel like I've met a couple of people that really
wanted to be different.
And I couldn't pull it off though.
You know they don't have the commitment I met a girl once and she was with her
sister and it was total innocent conversation.
You know nothing nothing crazy.
God said it was totally normal and she brought up something I think it had to do
with gay marriage.
I think it had to do with that and it was something about a bill being passed
and it was many many years ago so my memory's a little foggy but I do remember
this whenever the controversy was.
She said she goes it's not God's way.
And I said I remember like stopping and like all the sudden going whoa what
would happen with this conversation.
Like what did you just say.
It's not it's not God's way.
How do you know what God's way is.
Do you do you really talk to God.
Like where are you getting this from.
And she goes Oh that's Satan's his scales have covered your eyes.
She actually said that to me his scales have cut and I'll never forget me
looking at her and her sister and god damn you crazy bitches.
Yeah.
And the girl was.
She was so pretty too.
Oh my God she's beautiful.
She was like Latin or something like Donald's like oh crazy bitches.
Well you guys take care.
Just guys I was like we can't even talk.
You really think they're like Satanist scales and he puts it over your eyes.
We have so much work to do here.
I'm not taking on this project like to just just to communicate with you and get
you to a point of rational objective thinking.
We take three for mushroom trips right.
Have you heard of a guy named Pier Popoff.
He's a pastor.
He's televangelist guys.
What did he do.
Blow some money.
I saw him the other day I watched I was sleeping on the couch and I woke up in
his head when the shows are not paid shows commercials and I was amazed what
woke me up because I was kind of like half listening to while sleeping.
What was amazing how the things that they sang it just seemed illegal like they
were like you like oh you know we're gonna sing you some miracle water.
This water is you know miracle water you're going to open up these envelopes.
And then they start showing Mike testimonials like a people and they're like You
know I sent in my or I read the letters.
And then just a week later I got a new house in a car and then the next person
was like I got two hundred thousand dollars.
And then his other one like a guy just walked up and gave me a check for 15
million dollars and it was it was like the most fake shit ever.
And so then I started really researching this guy and there's all these videos
about him online.
I guess he's been ripping people off for a long time and one of the best videos
is one where he just goes up and he goes where's where so-and-so so-and-so is
here.
Let's let's say Tina.
Tina Fey.
Where are you.
And then she comes up because I heard you have arthritis and you're here because
you wanna get rid of this arthritis and stuff like that.
Oh the whole time his wife is just pumping the whole show.
Yeah.
She had a thing on it was on one of those 20 20 Yeah I don't like that.
Yeah I know we talked about this in the past.
I'm pretty sure maybe he's on another podcast but I was amazed that he's still
allowed to do that.
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Well that guy.
Well name one is not.
It's almost like it's.
That's so ridiculous.
It's like the most ridiculous hustle ever.
It's like Who are they.
Tricking the LNP with a trick and are like they're almost like mentally
challenged.
Oh yeah.
People with no hope.
When you're when you're just robots when you're down to being convinced that
there's a miracle water out there that is going to come in the mail via the
postal service and it's going to it's going to change your fortune right.
Yeah that's the one.
One of these things.
Somewhere along the line they used to ask for donations but then somewhere along
the line they they realized that they could sell things and they started like
selling like holy water and selling like prayer services and and telling people
that you would plant a seed.
So if you spend ninety dollars you Jill asked ninety dollars.
He would come back to you and tenfold.
The Bible says that would come out with some crazy fucking was that the guy
Creflo Dollar.
He's my favorite because he's got a dollar in his name.
I mean you're a pastor and your fucking name is dollar.
What's your read.
They all have weird names like that.
Okay I guess it Good Peter Popoff.
Have you ever met any other pop ups before.
This guy's got to have a different real name now.
He must have a real name what's his real name.
Wow his real name is Creflo Augustus dollar Junior.
Wow this is real fucking name.
Can a Bachelor of Science and Education
Center talking shit smack in people.
My favorite Robert Tilden.
You know he is.
You've probably seen him.
There's a viral video of him farting.
Like he's like he talks in tongues a lot on a show to Hugo.
Some like a chuckle love of my life my life you know my you know my level.
It's hilarious.
See if you could pull up Robert Tilton talking in tongues because it's some of
the most ridiculous shit ever.
But one I'll never forget this one thing he said he said every time you write a
check to me Satan gets a black eye.
Wow.
But it doesn't part of you think that if you're dumb enough to send him that
money like so what.
So a guy got you with the dumbest trick of all time like you really thought that
money was going to gone.
You really thought that money is gonna give the devil a black eye.
If you really thought that you're fucking stupid or not looking after you right.
One of the Scott things that this Peter Popoff does.
He also sends you a barley cake from the Bible where it's like kind of like that
little bread you eat.
And he goes he goes in this commercial he goes and we make it with the exact
ingredients that they say in the Bible and blah blah blah.
Well then if you look up Ezekiel 412 in the Bible it says and you should eat it
as barley cakes and bake it using fuel of human waste.
So the human way.
So.
So wait a minute wait a minute wait.
No it doesn't.
You want that typing in a for 412.
OK easy.
That's a Larry.
Hey I.
Hold on hold on.
Easy E K E L E for twenty four to twelve for twelve.
Yeah.
You're thinking about the we love but he kill for twelve a long time since I
read up on my good old days he kills.
This is all new to me baking with Don that comes out of man in their sight.
Hold it.
So he's saying hold on.
I can see our cooked fish.
Oh my God.
And thou shalt bake it with dung and that comes out of man in their sight.
Well it's in the Bible it's in the Bible.
Why do you need to study the Bible and cook you by hand with shit.
Have you ever tried my poo poo barley cake.
Fucking imagine how dumb people are.
That really hurts my brain.
Do you know Ezekiel Zeke might have been tripper because his ego was also where
the first depictions of UFOs came from.
He only pulled out.
Yeah Zeke Hill was known for.
There's there's a Bible quote that people bring up all the time was a UFO.
But people were seeing a lot of things after eating a shit.
Mainly they're eaten fucking shit cakes all day throwing out almost dying.
It was a wheel within a wheel.
It was God sharing it.
There was guys with boats they had all the animals.
You think we should prepare the barley cake in a different way.
No no it's great.
I'm trying to find Jesus.
What a stupid fucking culture.
I cook it with shit.
Okay Dad should I write that down on paper.
I put something in for violent my son because I got so obsessed with this
minister that so when I found that out I had tweeted something like Olive Garden
was like executive for 12 or something like that and all these people got pissed
off that I was due to doing Bible scriptures.
Oh that's hilarious.
Well they read that though.
Yeah they figured it out.
How do you not read that and just start laughing.
Told me to cook shit cakes.
Fuck the Bible says Cook shit cakes.
That's just one more dumb thing in the Bible.
God damn it I'm so tired of people pretending that books are awesome.
I'm so tired you stop that shit stupid.
Okay here here's a here's a quote and I looked and behold a whirlwind came out
of the North a great cloud and a fire in folding itself in brightness was about
it and out of the midst thereof as the color of Amber out of the midst of the
fire OK.
House audio file
hmm.
That's somebody putting two points together.
They don't go together for oh wait a minute this hold up.
And this also out of the midst there of came the likeness of four living
creatures and this was their appearance.
They had the likeness of a man.
Whoa.
After everyone had four faces and everyone had four wings and their feet were
straight and the sole of their feet was like the soul of a calf's foot and they
sparkled like the color of burnished brass.
What a trippy book.
People like Oh my God it's so real.
I hear God's words when you're saying these things.
God is speaking to me through your words please read on and they had the hands
of man under their wings on their four sides and they had and therefore had
their faces in their ways.
Somebody might have just made all this up and me like an asshole is reading this
fake Bible quote shitting all over the Bible and the aliens.
But guess what.
I don't care.
I'm not reading any further.
It seems like if this is if this really is as it kills it says it is God damn
it.
I think it's all nuttiness.
They walked up with their four faces and they said Why are you guys cooking
things in shit.
And the living creatures ran and returned as the appearance of a flash of
lightning.
Now as I behold the living creatures behold one wheel upon the earth by the
living creatures with his four faces.
These guys were tripping hard eating shit.
Kingsley yeah losing their mind.
What grows on shit.
Mushroom that's right.
Leave your shit takes out the cover with mushrooms.
Eat your shit cakes chip your balls off.
Stop talking nutty man.
When those went these went and when those stood still these stood and when those
were lifted up from the earth the wheels were lifted up.
That guy is this glass all alien.
That guy is just that's word salad.
That guy's high as fuck.
He just ramblin high as fuck.
I said the same thing in Joshua Tree one time and this is the stuff by the way
that they kept in you know.
I mean think about that like especially in the New Testament the New Testament.
They they had to like have like meetings inside Ed what's in there.
Yeah.
Leave this if you look at two crazy if you look at that is it go for twelve
quote.
Now it's totally changed has nothing to do like really lately different.
Oh they've altered the quote Well you know it also it's probably so hard.
You should talk to a linguist right.
You know I talked to a language scholar the other day ironically enough for a
Bigfoot show.
And if you talked to a linguist they'll tell you that it started off it was a
spoken story for the longest time before anyone even wrote it down.
And the the bible must many of the stories in the Bible probably existed before
language or before written language.
So like like a lot of the stories in the Bible also they're like really similar
to the same stories of ancient Mesopotamia.
Oh yeah.
Like somewhere and like the epic of Gilgamesh is like really close to the epic
of Noah Noah's Ark.
It's like it's really like a lot of similarities.
Yeah in a lot of the stories.
So they had to write it down the road down and probably let's say the first ship
was the Sumerians so they wrote it down and I think it's called cuneiform or
cuneiform.
They wrote it down then and then eventually it became ancient Hebrew and then
they're going to translate it ancient Hebrew to Latin and then as translated to
Greek as translated to English like they had to fuck it up in a lot of ways
along the way.
When you deal with some wacky ass languages.
Q Matt I mean how many people even exist and know how to convert all that shit.
Yeah I mean languages are lost.
Yeah.
And when they go over the the dead sea scrolls is the real trip factory.
Read some of the shit that's in the dead sea scrolls the dead sea scrolls of the
oldest version of the Bible by far by almost a thousand years I think it was
found in a place called Kumbh Ron in these these caves in the side of a mountain
like a side of a hill and these caves have these clay pots and in them with
these they literally made out of animal skins and it's the oldest stories of the
Bible and it's all trippy fucking shit it's all you read it and you go it makes
Ezekiel sound normal right.
And it's so nutty that even though it's the oldest version of the Bible they're
very resistant to release it.
And I like to say oh we're going to revise the bible now according to the dead
sea scrolls.
They're like you know what.
We've been reading this for a while.
Maybe we need to fucking just bury this bitch
because that's where that guy John Marco Allegro who's the the dead sea scrolls
guy.
He was like the head translator for the dead sea scrolls.
He said the whole thing was about mushrooms.
He his he wrote a book called The Sacred mushroom in the cross.
He was the only scholar on the whole dead sea scrolls committee that was
agnostic.
He was ordained minister but then studying theology realized it was horseshit
leaving booboo.
Yeah.
Say goodbye the people by guys.
We're gonna we're going to wrap this up soon anyway.
We're gonna get out of here too.
I got to go see the premiere of serious.
Dr. Steven Greer documentary where he reveals the truth about the tiny little
alien baby and whether or not it came from the planet Uranus.
We please text me immediately or live tweet.
Text me during it.
You know what.
What's going on.
I will text you but is a show only for you.
I will save the rest of it for when we talk on air.
So do not expect live tweets or spoilers.
I'm fascinated I actually talked to a really cool guy today at a video game
company that saw it last night and he said is really interesting.
So many get high as fuck and we'll see what's up later buddy.
I see tomorrow man George S.
Myanmar.
Yeah.
So this dead sea scrolls.
This guy John Marco Allegro said after like 14 years of study that the entire
Christian religion was really about fertility rituals and mushrooms.
It was about tripping balls on psychedelic mushrooms and it was about fertility
treatments and fertility festivals and that they would fertility rituals and
that like becoming pregnant was like the most important thing like keeping a
baby alive is really difficult and becoming pregnant and having you know a child
was like the most important thing to look forward to.
Like there was a serious urgency to having children because people were fragile
you know and they also knew a lot about the indigenous psychedelic plants and
especially what they think the Amanita miscarry mushroom he thinks was one of
the big ones that these people just didn't want anybody else to know about it so
they hid their stories.
They hit him in parables and you know they hid the how they know what their
history of the use of this stuff.
Really interesting stuff that I'm way too stupid to understand whether he's
right or whether the other people are right.
But the guy is a legit scholar you know he's not a stoner he's not like one of
those guys is trying to justify mushroom use.
There is something the Times that I've tried mushrooms in which I know it sounds
stereotypical but I really think there's something there.
I mean there's like definitely beyond science and rationale and what I've been
told to expect in this and that there's something there's something extra wild
about him and you know nothing's really that great as when you can really enjoy
that.
Yeah and and it makes for everything I mean luckily you know they're finally
coming out with these studies that are showing what it's doing for depression
and anxiety and it's it's super natural cure at times for people even with what
they called.
What are they come when it's a lifelong diagnosis.
Chronic depression.
I mean people have bounced out of it when they thought that they were going to
be miserable for the rest of their lives it's like Oh thanks a real
consciousness reset on a real life a real one not not not just like blowing on
your hand and pretending you feel better it's it's real it's legit.
Listen to some of the shit that's in the dead sea scrolls by the way.
There is people that are working really hard to try to turn that around as of
the John Hopkins study and yeah my friend Aubrey was just at maps the
psychedelic meaning whatever the hell it is I forget what the what it was I
stand for maps.
Same map psychedelic I should know because they're doing a lot of really good
work and letting people know it Intel multidisciplinary Association for
Psychedelic Studies and you know they're they're hitting them with hard science
over and over and over again and showing how many people it can be beneficial
for which model and a lot of people that are trying to hold back those people
that are trying to hold it back.
It would be beneficial to them as well so people don't understand is that your
desire for your resistance to psychedelics is the very reason you need
psychedelics in the first place.
If you really understood what you were resisting like you're really holding God
back you really you really want to believe in God.
Take 6 grams of mushrooms you'll see him.
Yeah you really party with them.
You'll hang out with them.
Dude DMV you'll have you'll meet God for sure.
You say it sounds crazy it sounds like an idiot saying it and I agree it's I.
It sounds like an idiot it's me.
I agree with you but I think it's probably exactly what Zeke was talking about
in that story.
But he was tripping his balls off.
Oh yeah.
He had some crazy psychedelic experience you probably ate some mushrooms or or
you know the Moses burning bush scholars to this day actively in in Jerusalem
there.
There's a movement for scholars to recognize the possibility that Moses was on
psychedelic drugs.
And that's one of the reasons why it's all a burning bush like one of the big
bushes that they that they associate with that area as the acacia tree the
acacia Bush rich and DMC.
And if that doesn't mean that if they figured out how to extract that shit and
smoke it burning bush is right there.
Yeah he met God.
He found out the 10 you know it sounds like what God would say of your high end
EMT all those ten commandments they sound pretty right.
Yeah.
Don't fuck your neighbor's wife.
Don't kill him.
Be nice.
Yeah it sounds like would be empty with W like it literally is exactly what
D.N.A.
would tell you.
Translated to the filters of time thousands of years of various languages.
But if some guy had some breakthrough experience back then I was trying to
enlighten all the people around him.
That's what he would say.
I came back from God.
God gave me this message and then over X amount of years of idiots talking about
it would not know.
Wrote it on stone tablets.
Well how did he know it was God's word.
Well God gave him.
Giants don't mean when people exaggerate and tell stories of course good a
thousand years of people explaining what happened they're going to fuck it up
and butcher it just makes sense.
What was the name of that Mel Brooks movie.
It's one of my favorite scenes in comedy history with Mel Brooks is playing
Moses and he comes around the corner at three tablets.
My Lord I give you these 15 and he drops the one these ten commandments.
Yeah.
So funny.
This is a this is a fucking fascinating.
These quotes I mean again I can't tell you if these quotes are really from the
actual dead sea scrolls but it's
it's really wild crazy shit.
It's it's it's hard to understand how you translate things to English because
it's not.
You're also trying to like display the intent with a completely different style
of communicating.
You know like this style of communicating that they had back then is probably so
alien to us like socially and so they try to alter it to get it to fit and how
we feel they would communicate if they lived today.
Yeah.
Many will attempt to steal your crown and rob you of your joy but they can never
succeed because of my presence with you.
What you have hidden in the deep recesses of your heart can never be removed by
the enemy of your soul.
Maintain a strong faith in me and my word and you shall never perish but enjoy
life everlasting which I have provided you.
That's sounds like a cult leader.
It sounds like a dude is trying to get his dick sucked and he knows where all
the gold is
yeah life everlasting.
That's a hard promise to keep.
Who knows if that's what it's really said though.
That's the really fascinating stuff about all this really ancient shit.
It's like piecing together the past so fucking hard to figure out when anybody
really said like this stuff that I've been telling you about this Dan Carlin's
Hardcore History that I've been listening to for the past couple of months.
They don't even know what gang is kind of looked like they don't only look like
they don't know where they buried them.
They don't they they don't have any direct quotes from him.
They have quotes from like people that met with like Russian historians like
emissaries and you know diplomats that met to like demand things before they you
know for the Mongols descended upon them.
Shit I read I read a thing about that exactly that they hired like 50 people to
bury gang is gone and then they hired 100 people to kill those 50 people so that
nobody knew where he was buried and then they hired 500 people to kill those
hundred people that killed the 50 people in case any of them told them a thing
you know and they would just ambush these groups of people that were under their
own command in order to protect the secret of gang is gone.
They're bad motherfuckers.
They were willing to take it to a level that human beings today could never
conceive of.
That's all I do now as I absorb all these these this is history is unbelievable
to me.
And now with the Internet you can go non stop tangent to tangent to tangent.
You can forget what originally got you there.
Next thing you could just be on the different scope of the universe.
But for some reason like tragic events of twelve A.D. don't bother me as much as
like Boston of 2013.
Like I stopped reading about the Boston tragedy.
Like I don't want to you know I'm hearing about this guy lost his legs and this
people you know these people were permanently injured and this person died and
it's you know it's so depressing.
But for whatever reason I can read about gangs can't or listen to this audiotape
bugging his car.
It doesn't bother me.
Yeah.
Sweet don't know how.
People are terrible they're capable of such horrible horrible behavior.
We don't know.
We're not used to or not around that often.
You have to see something happen to just understand.
Oh yeah there's some of us out there that are just fucking nuts right.
It's just in in in the evolution of things.
It's hard to it's hard to get all the way clear after a thousand years ago the
Mongol Lloyds were killing tens of thousands of Mongol Lloyd's great well with
long goals whatever
you can say whatever man they'll come they'll come get you.
The thing is China's like their hero.
I mean imagine like that's that's a guy that's in your your past.
You know we talk right.
What did what did your ancestors do.
Oh really.
My answer was getting his fuck my ancestor killed everybody because King is Khan
fucked so many people that he's responsible for a giant percentage of the DNA in
that area like he's in something like 5 percent his DNA is in some I just made
that number up.
By
the way I'm going to google it okay because it's not another fucking important
one of my historian.
Go look for yourself you.
If you want to find out get get that Dan Carlin's Hardcore History I can't
recommend it enough the guy puts a tremendous amount of work in these podcasts I
really respect his work ethic I'm not I'm fuckin fascinated by man Genghis Khan
motherfucker dude I'm saying Tony Hinchcliffe Oh yeah definitely.
So well what's next for you buddy.
Except besides Wednesday night at the ice house.
Can't wait for Wednesday Burt Chrysler and Tommy Segura and Bryan red band.
Jesus Luisa's I love it.
I'm very excited.
We're gonna have some fun.
Mm hmm mm hmm.
What else is going on for you.
Still working on Jeff Ross's show.
Yeah we're in between seasons right now.
Hopefully Season 3 will be really soon.
The burn on Comedy Central and you're one of the writers over there.
Yeah.
So if you see something really offensive most likely that guy wrote it you know
who did it Tony Hinchcliffe.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Even if I didn't write for it I fought for it to be on the show.
He's born gangster.
Look at that look at him.
It's true I not give a fuck.
Came out here from Ohio to make it in the dark world.
It's true.
What you from Columbus originally from Youngstown and a town in Italian city
between Chicago and New York.
I know where that is.
I did comedy there.
I did comedy in this club.
The funny farm.
Yeah.
And they had theirs there's the stages in the bag and there's a disco in the
front and the disco was like well it wasn't the highest end.
This guy you know not a holiday.
Yeah yeah.
Yeah.
And there was like all this music was playing every time the back door would
open.
You would hear
it
and then it would close and then you'd go back to your act.
It
would be like literally this quiet.
And the door would open.
So it's just constant open and shut into pee.
You had to go that way I think yeah I might have made that up to now.
No it wasn't a good gig.
That club was notoriously like.
Not really.
Did you ever do it.
No.
Never.
Some areas started out here.
So do you wanna go back to just let everybody know I went back a couple of times
when I first started and did pretty big shows at a different bar.
But I was at a bar.
Oh you just did like you got your own thing.
Yeah.
Looking you fuckin stud.
Would you do with you bring somebody.
It was just me actually just you by yourself.
Yeah I have.
You're a savage.
Yeah I have a big a good great group of friends back in Youngstown.
How much time do you have altogether.
Well altogether it's weird because no matter what I'm trying to do I always go
off on tangents and whatever so that's always I have to end up doing less than
my goal anyway.
And you makes a good problem to have.
Yeah yeah it is that you get that problem we do a lot of comedy.
Yeah I do a lot of comedy on stage yeah.
How many days a week are you going up every night.
That's how you do it.
Some nights like last week I had a couple nights where it was three shows in one
night flying around just doing it.
Isn't it amazing when you do that because coming home comes party DNA you know
really gets in that groove.
It's hard to do.
Trying to do.
Oh yeah.
I find I balance.
I like to do that.
I never liked you every night.
I like to do like three or four nights a week.
Then I like to take nights a week off and not even think about comedy and just
write where I don't I don't even I don't even entertain the idea of going
onstage.
I just go over ideas you know and I find that there's like for me I can't just
always be going onstage.
It's like a lot of time has to be spent especially now working on I don't know
like my sixth or seventh hour or something like that and all the time I put out
specials and shit.
It's like I have to I have to figure out like new angles and new points of view
and not even this whole new point of view.
But new subjects new new different things that interests me new points that I
have.
I feel like I don't I don't just get that I I just go on stage a lot.
I have to spend a lot of time doing other shit you know and I think about that
actively now whereas when I was younger than I really think about that actively
like I would just try to like right you know I just try to come up with new bits
but now I make myself do things.
So the cool stuff will come out of my interesting stuff to talk about.
It was very soon after I started standup once and the first couple weeks I found
a book that Stephen King wrote called on writing yeah great book unbelievable
because it's a it's obviously you know it's not a fiction he's just talking
about his work ethic of writing and he's like I don't think I'm a writer if I
take a day off what am I that I'm just some guy.
And so I started applying that during the day and I figured you know on top of
writing my own standup if I keep up this habit of writing for a few hours every
day during the day
then then it will get better.
And it did.
Sure enough you know luckily I'm a member of the Writers Guild now.
Yeah.
Working on the show and everything.
So the habit was really it was that book that gave me the confidence because
you're listening to Stephen King.
I mean yeah.
One of the best at what he does.
So one of the best of all time.
Yeah yeah.
I mean I'm a huge fan of that guy and I just I can't have a thing about people
that produce stuff.
Yeah I find that like for me one of the most inspirational things is to be
around a lot of other inspirational people you know like when I like when I go
to a UFC I want to work out and after I come home I want to fucking work out
like crazy when I go see comedy.
I want to write and I think that's what's really important.
Oh totally.
I do that all the time even with the music that I listen to.
Going somewhere getting ready for something you know at night.
I listen a big powerful music that'll get me you know sort of hyped and inspired
a lot of live shows is that type of music that I listen to and you hear the
crowd just yeah.
Yeah.
In these breaks or at the beginnings or at the end of the song and that's the
stuff that takes every little bit of Mojo one can absorb to be able to kick it
back out.
Yeah that's why I really like music as well.
I think music is one of the cool things to see because it's like the energy is
putting it but it's totally different from comedy.
It's like some new facet of some new energy some new thing.
And like when I listen to a song like some songs or suck something about it like
like there's a lyrical quality to like writing in songs that I started to
realize somewhere along the line is applicable to comedy as well.
Like when a good joke is written correctly and a joke has a good economy of
words and the right words to describe the right situations it has like a
rhythmic quality to it.
And I think that's sort of that's sort of underestimated or overlooked by a lot
of comedians.
The impact that that sort of rhythm to the delivery has the impact of it I think
is pretty substantial.
Oh totally.
But we don't think about that we just think about what is funny but it's not
just that it's like it's funny and it's also good and it's smooth and it's a lot
of things to it to make it more enjoyable more interesting to listen to.
A perfect example of what you're talking about right now with the rhythm and
like timing and everything.
Last night I'm hosting at the Comedy Store it's like 40 comedians everybody
that's new and employees after that and then paid regular whatever and in the
middle of it a cook that the Mexican guy Aldo don't show who works the deep
fryer at the Comedy Store.
Hey man I want to go on stage and barely speaks English at all.
I mean the impression I just did is making him sound much more American than he
is.
And he he wants to do comedy and I go you know what man.
All right.
But it's just gonna be two minutes okay.
This way in case it's you know do whatever is right.
But you know and he goes up.
But it was hilarious because nobody could understand a single word but he was
completely committed and then all of a sudden he's making this noise and you
really you don't you don't know even know what the noise he was making was but
his commitment and his beats with it just he crushed he crushed and all these
other comedians that do it every night and look at going up in that room at the
Comedy Store is like this is it.
I'm going to show them what I would do on The Tonight Show if I was on it
tonight.
Then you have the guy work in the frying pans who nobody understands a word.
There's people that spend so much time writing and everything but there he is.
And it sure it's a silly instance but it was extremely funny.
If I'm cracking up and the audience is laughing and people are then it's funny.
And but you know it's really and he did it without a word.
How do you how do you recreate that could you recreate that with another
audience.
Maybe not.
And make maybe that would only work in that sort of a really lose situation
where it's a comedy store.
Bunch comedians in the crowd right.
You want to go up you go up and like no expectations right.
You know I mean it's like Could you recreate that and become a comedian.
Right.
It was yeah because you know how that that's a weird realization you have where
just because a joke kills in one place it could bomb another place of total and
you say it the exact same way.
Yeah well what the fuck yeah.
And then you realize well well there isn't like this isn't always work like this
this weird idea I'm throwing out there yeah some people are gonna buy into it
and some people are not.
And sometimes it sounds like the greatest joke ever written.
Sometimes it sounds like you're a fool.
Yeah because sometimes there's something that happened the first time you did it
when it worked that you did before that you don't normally do that you forgot
that you did and it worked because of that.
And I think a good thing for young comics to realize is that that's good.
It's good.
All those bombing and failing and not getting it right.
Oh yeah totally.
Because if you don't have it you're not going to appreciate when it goes well.
I remember in my first few weeks of doing it somebody went to a comedian came up
to me who I won't say his name but he was terrible.
And he goes Hey man you know the trick is bomb as often as you can.
I'm thinking myself Oh yeah that's what you would do you'll lose there if that's
what you're doing anyway.
But mostly I got Americans to bomb.
What was his rationale.
Well he goes you know because now's the time to knock bombing out.
Oh you know how to bomb now.
It ended up making some sense Labor's terrible.
So how did you have such wisdom.
Right exactly.
Somebody must have.
Somebody must have told him that like hey you know look at it this way in a
positive sense you're bombings.
Good.
I don't think back means funny anymore makes me sad.
It's funny to you right now.
So close yeah.
Now just madness.
I look at it I just see madness this people that you know that are going to try
for years and years and years and know it's never gonna happen right doesn't
exist for them.
Yeah
it is creepy and I've seen it with a few people but you with anything.
I mean you watch American Idol and people saying and you like how is this person
think they've been saying they're crazy.
How does this person think anything what anybody wants it must be that for if
you're a literary agent.
I mean imagine how many people send you secret stories like Holy fuck are you
reading this nuts fucking work.
Read this.
What what is that.
Tony why why are some people so goddamn delusional.
Is there a broad spectrum of human beings and the amount of voltage your battery
puts out and some people are just designed to dig holes.
I think that the delusion is you know the delusion needs to be that with tons of
work at something you can accomplish it.
Not that the delusion is I can do this.
It's you've got to everybody that has ever been good at anything worked at it
you know and I mean a lot.
So it's not and they wanted it.
And even if you work out it doesn't mean you gonna get it.
Especially with things like talent things like talent is a weird thing.
Like these guys I've seen guys that like they train striking like for MDMA.
They train it for years.
They fucking trained for years.
But then when it comes and actually fight they can't pull it off.
They just they can't strike with people again.
They don't move right.
They're too slow for whatever reason it is they can never figure it out.
And there's other guys who show em a couple of moves they lose like fucking pros
like instantly and they crush you and knock you out with one punch.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like either.
I mean it's like that guy clearly has a gift right.
This guy clearly no matter how hard he works he's never going to get there.
It's true.
The weird thing about this life boy must be a real curse led to a crazy feeling
to be one of those guys.
It's like trying to pursue something and you having no success and you can't
connect the dots and you can't move forward.
Man it's you know before anything was happening you know before when I was still
not making money and before I was getting past at the clubs and Hollywood and
everything it was extremely low.
You know I was able to keep having fun by surrounding myself around funny
friends and everything but man was it hard.
Yeah it's depressing Yeah pressing as fuck when you're not making it deck out
there.
It's hard but isn't it like a real character builder.
Once you're through to the other side.
Like oh yeah he must be so happy right now.
Oh yeah.
Yeah you're always smiling and shit.
I'll totally you're like a professional comedian.
Boom got through.
It's wild.
You made it.
Yeah dude you you know you fucking killed in Indianapolis.
There's a lot of goddamn people's 2000 people out there and you had to go up
cold and we knew who the fuck you were.
I love it.
Kill.
That's right.
That's the way I like it.
Yeah.
The audience loved you.
I love love.
A lot of positive tweets.
Man I thought you're funny.
Yeah it was a blast.
I listened to the set the next day and I just couldn't even believe it.
This was really wild.
So we caught all those in the sound and the power of that one was that the
biggest crowd you ever worked.
I think so right or right around there.
I should know but it's it's been right around there with a couple of shows the
quote that was sorry about this guy Phil Elmore.
He's a writer.
He wrote this on his Twitter.
So as a writer never has a vacation for a writer life consists of either writing
or thinking about writing.
And that's Eugene you know sick go.
He was a playwright.
That's so true.
Psycho.
I can't sleep at night if I didn't do something that day.
It's not a vacation.
I'm.
I work my vacation.
I think this is a blast.
I would be uncomfortable for me is literally being on an island for a week with
no internet and no.
Yeah.
Pen and paper.
Well people that don't stand that like you need to relax Tony.
You need to stop working so hard they understand that you're the only person
that can make Tony Hinchcliffe jokes right.
If somebody likes you you're the only person that that makes you.
You're the only person that performs in your view you know that's it.
That's the only Tony Tony him Thomas.
Tony Hinchcliffe show around no one else can do it unless they're in Vegas years
from now doing an impersonator act.
Right.
Right history is the autobiography of a madman Alexander Herman son of bad ass
quote.
I read today might be good wit in this show.
Tony Hinchcliffe thank you for being a bad mother fucker.
Thank you so much for coming along and and being one of those guys that I to
enjoy.
Enjoy your comedy man.
Happy to be part of it.
Happy to have you.
Welcome.
That's quite a bitch.
All right.
Thanks everybody for tuning into the podcast tomorrow.
We'll be back with the greatest welterweight champion in the history of mixed
martial arts.
George NPR my friend joins us.
People say what you do to George Sapir impression in front of him only with
George's blessing.
What the fuck that means Tony.
Help me out here the slack pick up the slack Tony.
You mean George St.
Peter is gonna be sitting in this chair.
Yeah.
Don't rub your dick on it.
Son of a bitch.
Thanks a square space dot com.
Go to square space dot com forward slash Joe and sign up.
Use the offer code Joe for and save 10 percent off your first purchase on new
accounts 30 bucks.
Thanks to Audible dot com go to Audible dot com forward slash Joe and you'll get
one free audio book and 33 days of audible service.
Thanks also to taking candid talk.
What is it Rogan dot dot com or something like that.
UPDATE ON A SECOND THING.
YEAH.
Rogan ducting dot com.
Go there your fox and save 25 bucks.
Think.
Yeah.
Twenty five bucks off of either a phone or service and they're an awesome
company and they're very nice to us and then know my mom we make really shitty
commercials like this.
Thanks to everybody else thanks to on it use the code name Rogan save 10 percent
of O and I tee off any other supplements and that's it ladies and gentlemen I
apologize for my brain being mush lately I've been working a lot on this other
show as well as doing this and I feel it I feel it Tony I feel stupid.
Help me out buddy.
May 3rd 4th and 5th.
San Francisco Sacramento.
The Death Squad says Tony Hinchcliffe in the House pitches.
That's it.
All right folks.
We will see you tomorrow.
We love the shit out of you.
And Godspeed.
Not because.